is your one minute warning this meeting
good morning everyone and welcome to the
Tuesday edition of the science
technology and energy committee for
January 31st
2023 the last day of January
as usual we will start our meeting by
all rising and joining representative
Corman as he leads us in the Pledge of
Allegiance
thank you today we'll be hearing
six bills here in St e
starting in just a moment with HP 234
relative to renewable energy credits
at roughly 10 o'clock we'll move on to
HB 246 relative to the use of monies in
the renewable energy fund
at 11 we'll move on to HB 161 relative
to customer generators of electricity as
group hosts under net metering
after the lunch break we'll be back at 1
30 for HB 165.
relative to Department of energy
procedures in lieu of meeting renewable
portfolio standards for biomass
at 2 30 we'll move on to HB 166 relative
to the elimination of useful thermal
energy from renewable energy classes
and we'll wrap up the day at 3 30
approximately with HB 81 establishing a
study committee to examine all ancillary
representative Thomas and I had a
discussion yesterday
about the
inefficient use of our time yesterday
and so we're going to be proposing to
the members of the committee a change in
strategy going forward but I'm going to
wait and do that later today in the
hopes that more members will be here by
then because I'd like to like to get a
consensus from the members about whether
or not they think our new strategy will
work
so we'll do that probably right after
lunch
so now we can begin one other
administrative issue I'll be leaving
here at 9 15 to go to a chairs meeting
so representative Thomas will take over
at that point
so with that I think we can start and so
I will open the public hearing on House
Bill 234 relative to renewable energy
credits and call on the bills Prime
sponsor representative Rebecca
McWilliams to present this bill good
morning representative good morning
chair Bose good morning members of the
committee it's a pleasure to be here
with you back-to-back days of hearings
for the record my name is Rebecca
McWilliams I represent South Concord so
let's talk about renewable energy
credits and renewable energy credit
sweeping
um this bill is really simple if you
look at the language it's simply
um repeals
a practice that we've been doing for
several years that apparently
um
for a lot of technical reasons that I
will get into this practice really
doesn't serve us as a state and it also
appears to be against the values of
liberty and justice that I believe New
Hampshire was founded on
so let's talk about renewable energy
credits and what this bill is all about
New Hampshire is one of 29 U.S states
that have implemented a renewable
portfolio standard
these state level policies have been
responsible for approximately half of
the growth in U.S renewable electricity
generation and capacity since 2000 23
years half the growth
New Hampshire's renewable portfolio
standard or RPS is a policy that
obligates our electricity suppliers like
eversource Unice Hill and Liberty
to acquire a certain percentage of their
electricity mix from renewable energy
sources every year
our renewable obligations are divided
into four categories new renewable
energy is class one new solar is class
two class three is existing biomass and
methane and class 4 existing small Hydro
there are three ways that our
electricity suppliers in New Hampshire
can comply with the renewable energy
obligations under the RPS the first and
generally the one that's done the most
is to purchase renewable energy credits
this was always intended to be the way
that our utilities ended up getting
energy efficient energy into their mix
every megawatt hour of electricity
generated from a renewable energy system
produces a renewable energy credit or a
wreck
this is a certificate acknowledging the
potential contribution to the RPS
electricity suppliers can purchase
wrecks from homeowners I have solar on
my house so I am able to collect wrecks
also from businesses municipalities or
other owners of renewable energy systems
in order for the utility to comply with
RPS obligations through the rec Market
also they can pay alternative compliance
payments rather than buying wrecks
so they pay into the renewable energy
fund and the Public Utilities Commission
uses the monarchy money that is
generated by these alternative
compliance payments to fund rebate
programs for residential commercial
Municipal and low-income renewable
energy projects
the third option which we're not seeing
any of the utilities actually use is to
build Renewables obviously we have some
serious regulatory challenges
um our utilities are not actually
allowed to be producers so this is a
very rarely used option but it is the
third that a utility could build
renewable energy production
so there are multiple auctions every
year and prices vary for Rex nonetheless
currently the way the system is set up
there is a system called wreck sweeping
um and
homeowners who have decided not to take
advantage of the Renewable Energy Credit
Market
um
will nonetheless have their wrecks
applied to the utilities of New
Hampshire or the energy companies of New
Hampshire
for for their own use basically
so Rex weak being is a loophole in the
renewable portfolio standard that allows
electric suppliers to sweep up on
registered wrecks without paying the
owners of the systems that generated
them
the surplus of free Rex distorts the
market by causing wreck prices to
collapse
wreck prices in New Hampshire are
incredibly low
sometimes less than 10 often less than
five dollars a wreck
the low price of Rex is both a symptom
of wreck sweeping and also the cause of
wreck sweeping we are in a vicious cycle
because prices are so low many
residential and small scale systems do
not bother to register and sell their
wrecks so it creates this culture of
apathy where oh if my wrecks are worth
so little it's not worth me going
through the steps to register them
however they're worth so little because
of wreck sweeping which is creating this
chicken and egg cycle where I really
should be getting the value of my Rex
but they've been so undervalued from
getting swept to the utilities that why
should I bother it's not worth my time I
would posit that this is probably the
exact opposite of what we intended to do
back when we set up this program
requiring that utilities meet their
renewable portfolio standard we've
created a loophole so that instead
they're just sweeping into it House Bill
234 closes the rec sweeping loophole
that allows utilities to take
unregistered wrecks from Renewable
Energy Systems owners at no cost the
Cornerstone of clean energy policy is
broken
so I'm just going to speak a little bit
more about the technicalities of the
program
as we discussed Rec sweeping enables
utilities and competitive Supply
suppliers to meet the overall majority
of their RPS obligations in specific
it's their solar obligations that
they're able to meet of those four
classes that we discussed solar is
really the one that's being undermined
by wreck Sweeping in fact more than
two-thirds of Class 2 solar obligations
were met with Rex in 2021
two-thirds swept Rex utilities got it
for free
and approximately ninety percent of the
obligation was likely met with swept
wrecks in 2022
um we're going to get more data on that
when it's published in the absence of
Rex sweeping it is fully possible that
the renewable portfolio standard could
have promoted 10 times the amount of
solar energy achieved and so what that
means is we're losing out on the benefit
of a real renewable mix which is
required by the RPS because Rec sweeping
just puts a Band-Aid over that
so how's this possible ostensibly the
New Hampshire RPS requires utilities and
competitive energy suppliers to purchase
an increasing percentage of the energy
that they sell from renewable sources
according to the New Hampshire energy
fund annual report in 2022 the standard
way to demonstrate RPS compliance is for
the utilities and competitive suppliers
to either purchase or make acps we've
talked about this
however we currently have a statute RSI
RSA 362 F6 Roman 2A customer generators
that do not undertake the burdensome
costly and time-consuming series of
actions necessary to register the
renewable generation with the Public
Utilities Commission and knee pool are
subject to what has come to be called
wreck sweeping so I've handed out just a
very simple two-page handout that is
available on eversources website to
anyone who's interested in
how can eversource help me with
renewable energy credits I'm just going
to skim this briefly because I want you
to understand that there definitely is a
burden to registering for Rex and as I
discussed the chicken and egg problem
where it's become such a hassle and it's
not worth a lot of money because we have
basically diluted the market and we're
giving utilities Wrecks for free they're
not paying anything for them
so these wrecks often go unclaimed so
let's just say that you install a solar
system at your residential home
um Step number one you have the solar
system consider engaging the services of
a wreck aggregator so you're not
required to hire a third-party wreck
aggregator but customers often choose to
work with a reg aggregator to do the
paperwork for them so there is a list of
Rec aggregators on eversource's website
then you need to open an account with
the New England power pool generation
information system knee pool GIS
and register your renewable energy
project so either you or your aggregator
can do this once again it's an
additional step you create the account
and then it's monitored it's then you
need to read inside an agreement between
Next Step number four complete nhpuc
class one or Class 2 Rec eligibility
application so that application is also
available on the website more paperwork
step five you need to install an
appropriate Rec meter socket as part of
your solar energy project this is if
you're doing solar
um and there are guidelines for exactly
what that means
then finally you need to submit digital
pictures of your Rec meter socket to
eversource so if this sounds burdensome
to you you can imagine that it's
probably pretty burdensome to the
average consumer who's saying well
what's in it for me if I'm only going to
get five to ten dollars a wreck and I
have a very small system you know this
just sounds like burden some paperwork
and I would agree I think that that's
kind of the way that this has turned out
to be but it doesn't have to be this way
and it could be a lot better if we were
to get rid of sweeping racks
um so getting back to the technical
document on this once a customer
generator is renewable attributes
um have been swept by the utility
because they don't claim them and they
don't do these steps they're no longer
entitled to claim renewable energy they
generate as their own so this is more
important for commercial than for
residential but you're not able to
advertise that you are a farm run by
solar if you didn't claim your wrecks
technically they belong to your utility
and so you're not a farm run by solar
your utility gets the benefit of saying
they get that solar from your farm
um in order to legally claim and use the
renewable energy your solar array
generates you must retain exclusive
rights to your Energy's renewable
attributes including the right to
exclude the utilities from using your
Rex for RPS compliance
to do otherwise
would violate Federal anti-double
counting regulations and New Hampshire
law but New Hampshire's statutory
statutorially authorized practice of
wreck sweeping has deprived New
Hampshire customer generators of the
right to prevent electricity suppliers
from being allocated and using swept
wrecks so Rec sweeping is therefore a
taking without notice or compensation
and it violates the New Hampshire
constitutional guarantee of property
right protection under part one articles
2 and 12. wreck sweeping has not only
allowed the utilities and competitive
suppliers to evade their obligations to
promote renewable energy generation and
Independence in New Hampshire it is also
indirectly depressed wreck prices wreck
sweeping and low wreck prices have
largely gotten rid of the need for
electricity providers to pay alternative
compliance payments which would fund the
renewable energy fund so here we are
sitting in a situation with a chicken
and egg and also I would say a violation
of our Liberty and rights by simply
giving away wrecks that don't belong to
the utilities and suddenly they can use
them to fulfill a different obligation
this in turn has reduced represents
excuse me are you are you near the end I
am one minute yep okay this in turn has
reduced rebates and incentives to New
Hampshire businesses and residents that
could have spurred private investment in
renewable energy it's also prevented
diversification of our state's fuel
sources leaving us over reliant on
natural gas and this has contributed to
the current spike in electricity costs
because of international issues with the
cost of natural gas in short Rec
sweeping is a pernicious statutory
provision and it should be removed from
our rsas
so that covers my testimony and the
technical document that I handed out I'm
happy to answer any questions about this
bill
thank you representative uh and for an
excellent uh review of what the of what
the wreck as you call it sweeping
program does and doesn't do so thank you
for that
um I've seen the representative Winnie
Thomas's hand up first for a question
good morning guys thank you Mr chair and
uh thank you for this presentation
um I just it seems pretty
straightforward I just have one question
um is anyone allowed to opt out of this
wreck sweeping or is it it's just
overpowering and it's something that's
done to you
um so I thank you representative Wendy
Thomas
um I don't want to steal the Thunder of
a bill that I have filed separately from
this bill but there is a bill to address
notice to folks who could potentially do
um do the certificates and don't realize
that they can and need some more notice
that's a separate bill but the way that
this works is basically if you don't opt
in and this is an opt-in process you saw
the seven steps with eversourced opt-in
if you don't opt in then you're assumed
to have opted out and so therefore the
utility can sweep your wrecks okay thank
you very much
thank you um and uh may I suggest uh not
in this case but on any questions the
answers please be direct to the question
and uh for time considerations uh any
further explanation perhaps should be
hell for a further question this will
become more important when the cheer
discusses our strategy for bills coming
in in the future uh representative
JD Bernardi another question
thank you Mr chair
um so you call this a loophole yet it is
law defined set of uh
principles and characterized in the law
and if we were to end it
would not that increase the cost to rate
payers by raising the cost of
electricity
thank you for your question
representative Bernardi to the first
part where I called this a loophole that
tends to be the nature of what happens
with legislation we as a body pass
multiple bills in multiple years and
sometimes they differ sometimes one new
bill changes a previous bill that's
pretty much what happened in this
situation where we had a goal for the
renewable portfolio standard and then
later on WE introduced as a legislature
Rec sweeping that pretty much undermines
the goal so it created that situation I
called a loophole because the utilities
could choose not to do it but they all
choose to do it it's the simplest
easiest way to meet the requirement and
we haven't patched the loophole to
prevent that and get back on track with
our goals for the renewable portfolio
standard the second piece of your
question about how the cost is allocated
there is certainly a value to Rex and so
whoever decides to install a solar array
could collect on that value of those
wrecks they've constructed it they've
put money in their probably paying a
long-term loan payment to pay off the
solar that they installed at their
property and so they are entitled to the
value of those wrecks when they're sold
at auction and when they choose not to
get them that value of the Rex is then
going to the utilities so what we're
essentially doing is a taking without
permission of the folks who either
failed to forgot to didn't know they had
to get wrecks or decided it wasn't worth
their value suddenly that money is
shifted over to the utility
so when you talk about overall cost to
the consumers of New Hampshire right now
what we're doing is we're allowing the
utilities to have free money from people
who spent their own money to create
these wrecks and that's not right it's
not fair
but yes of course it has hurt the market
and it has underinflated the value of
the Rex and therefore once we correct
the market there will be an increased
value and an increased distributed cost
which is what it should have been all
along on the ratepayers of New Hampshire
who have been generally benefiting from
this program that unfairly takes wrecks
from people who have already invested in
and don't realize or don't know or in
some cases don't think it's worth it to
get the value in the aggregate the value
is significant but for individual
projects and individual bills very very
small
a lot follow-up so
so you acknowledge that by eliminating
this program we would increase cost
overall cost of electricity to Consumers
point one and you acknowledge the fact
that the legislature deliberately
created the program
to allow this to occur
so I want to be very clear how I respond
to representative Bernardi I think to
point one
when we talk about installing new solar
across the entire State we're talking
about increasing our diversity in our
mix which overall will decrease the cost
of natural gas which is what we're
relying on because we have other sources
to rely upon so in the 10-year plan
which is really what my focus is on this
saves everyone money by getting us back
to the renewable portfolio standard but
yes you are correct in the short term if
we are counting pennies there is a cost
to everyone to get back to that plan
okay yeah in interest of time I'll allow
one more question
okay so so again what you're saying is
by
allowing the utilities to take
Rex which have been abandoned by the
their uh their owners
it would increase the cost of power
overall to the customer base
I wouldn't say that no I'm sorry I think
you and I differ on how this is actually
executed I would say that it corrects
the market and therefore over time saves
bye
uh before I call the next oops okay
represent Harrington has a question
yeah I'm trying to figure this out
you've mentioned a couple of times about
Distortion of the market and
um illegal taking but uninfect directs a
simply they just Fiat that was created
by the legislature anybody could put up
a solar panel any place they want but it
has no wreck value except for the law
that was created that Awards them values
there's no intrinsic value to their
product other than the electricity they
sell they get to sell that and then
above and beyond they get this Fiat
money which was just by the power of the
state is that not correct I mean
basically a wreck is only valuable
because the state says the utilities
must buy them
thank you for your question
representative Harrington a wreck has
value because we've created a market for
that wreck there is a actual tangible
dollar value for every single auction
that happens multiple times a year for
these wrecks there is a real dollar
value that is then swept to the
utilities so we've created as a
legislature just like we as the federal
government could create money we could
print money it's the same sort of thing
legislatively we've created that market
follow-up
I I guess what I'm confused on is it
seems like you the the state is awarding
something a piece of paper for every
megawatt of qualified electricity that's
produced that paper has no value other
than the fact that the state has created
a market so how can the state taking
some of that back be an illegal taking
because it's a totally a creation of the
state to begin with nobody has a
constitutional right to Iraq do they I
mean is there some part of the
Constitution I missed that talks about
thank you representative Harrington
we've created this market we've created
a supply and demand and therefore we've
created a value and yes there is a
dollar value for every wreck it varies
per auction but there is a dollar value
and unfortunately right now that dollar
value is just being awarded to the
utilities I would say that we need to
stop this practice in order to make sure
that the value we've created is honored
one quick follow-up Mr chairman you must
have a follow-up and let's very very
quick when you say awarded to the
utilities in fact you do mean the
utilities don't make a profit they just
simply pass whatever that award is to
the rate payers in the form of lower
rates is that not correct
the utilities are able to meet their
renewable portfolio standard by sweeping
these solar wrecks and therefore they do
not need to make alternative compliance
payments those are real dollars those
are dollars avoided so when we talk
about money we're talking about the
utilities being able to save money by
not having to spend money to purchase
okay uh seeing no other questions thank
you so much
representative partial uh please in the
interest of time a quick question
let's just be the last one please thank
you chair
I'm seeing uh on the paper you handed
out uh
your uh paragraph five mentions the
other source Rec meter socket
requirements
and this is somewhat new to me could you
please tell me if I
do I have to have one of them installed
or can they estimate
what the wrecks are produced and sweep
on that basis
you know I'm probably not the right
person to answer this question about the
eversource meter socket I think that's
probably a little more technical there
will be people after me who can respond
to that better well I hope so I wanted
to goodness in case we don't have ever
Source here today thank you
okay say uh I'm gonna call on thank you
very much for your testimony I'll call
on the next um
uh testifier which will be the honorable
Lee auctionham welcome back to the
committee
thank you Mr chair good to be back
um Lee auction I'm speaking for myself
the fundamental purpose of this bill is
to put in indirect sweepings
unconstitutional taking of customer
generators property that is the
renewable attributes of their renewable
energy generation it's not created by
Fiat by the state it's created at the
moment the energy is produced and as the
doe testified last week renewable
attributes are the property that makes
renewable energy renewable renewable
energy has a great value in the market
and this loophole is something that is
done by the state not by the utilities
this is a taking by the state of the
property of New Hampshire residents and
businesses it is done without their
knowledge or consent or any compensation
that is not legal
first wreck sweeping is it taking
because electricity providers are
enabled to use customer generators
property for their own purposes using
your property for their purposes
is it taking because in so doing it
prevents the customer generator from
being able to use their own property in
their own interests denying the property
owner the use of their property and it
is also a taking because it makes the
original owner liable to prosecution
thank you for staying for my testimony
sir
due to anti-double-counting rules and
laws against false advertising
further well with the test fire suspend
please direct your testimony to the to
the bill and uh beside instead of other
side comments please
thank you sir I was answering his
question and I
excuse me for
the aside
although we keep being told that swept
wrecks go to public utilities to meet
their RPS obligation and indirectly that
should lower rates by an inconsequential
amount almost exactly half of the total
goes to private corporations mostly out
of state multi-billion dollar
corporations like Constellation Energy
those funds are not being used to lower
rates they are being used by for private
purposes by those corporations probably
going to their shareholders
as you heard earlier if you separate the
renewable attributes from the
electricity produced by renewable source
that energy is no longer renewable it is
classified by the FTC as null
electricity
all the renewable attributes and we
commonly slur this over and refer to
them as wrecks
all the renewable attributes for
renewable portfolio standard compliance
legally
become part of the electricity the
providers Supply and RPS anti-double
counting rules prohibit anyone else from
claiming they also use those same
renewable attributes as something they
produce or consume that's the problem
with double County the only way you can
prevent double counting is to ensure
only one owner to those renewable
attributes if they are swept they now
belong to whoever holds the wreck which
is the legal title to the renewable
attributes the certificate is not the
property the renewable attributes are
the property
federal law I'll give you 30 seconds
please Federal also prohibits customer
generators from claiming to use
renewable energy they produce if it's
counted towards an RPS mandate wreck
sweeping also renders null and void the
customer generator's intention to move
off of fossil fuels it subverts their
intent to make additional renewable
energy beyond the legally mandated
minimum in order to accelerate the clean
energy transition and finally it's a
double whammy by producing energy that
meets their own needs customer
generators already reduce the total
amount of energy subject to compliance
requirements and because the RPS only
applies to electricity that this
utilities and the private companies sell
so the state's already applying swept
wrecks against an already reduced RPS
obligation the net result we would have
had more renewable energy in New
Hampshire if all of those residents
thousands and businesses had never
invested their hard-earned money at all
if if uh thank you chair and thank you
representative take my question
so right now the relax that the
customers
do not apply for within one year if I
believe that's the agreement right as it
is now the utilities sweep them
and this bill proposes instead of the
utilities taking their property the
state will take the property
for what the state believes is a better
use if you would like to
the previous speaker often used the term
claimed or unclaimed the issue here is
that this it it's not that the utilities
are claiming the wrecks what the
utilities do is they fill out a form and
they say how much electricity they sold
the state then applies a formula to that
and credits them with Rex that they have
not paid for
that the actual owners of the renewable
attributes the original owners who
invested their money who generated the
electricity who think they're using
renewable energy those people have lost
the value of their renewable attributes
because of the states taking of their
property without their knowledge consent
or compensation
did that answer the question or did I
you got me confused when you mentioned
uh uh thank you
for Clear uh thank you sir for
when this when the utilities
sweep
and become
the person who is property presumed
cannot use them now how does when the
state takes them that person gets that
value from the state so it's because
otherwise they lose either way they
don't get that value and it's their
decision not to
it's only your decision if you know
about the process
and as was mentioned there is a bill
about notifying people that this process
exists and has been going on for about a
decade so people who are being harmed
are unaware of it people who put who put
their house on the market and say the
house is solar
uh powered can be sued for false
advertising people who businesses who
put uh panels on their roofs and then
say our manufacturing process is
renewable or even if they use a picture
of their Factory with the with the
renewable energy shown it's false
advertising if you've sold your wrecks
you do not have renewable energy you are
not producing renewable energy that
value has been lost it's been taken by
the state and transferred not just to
the utilities but to private
corporations almost fully have it's
something like 47.9 percent
goes to private corporations for private
uses does not reduce rate payers
bills by ascent
and where it does produce some savings
okay seeing other questions and I'll
okay go ahead last one
thank you Mr chair so you declared that
this reps week sweeping is
unconstitutional taking
yet the state created the wrecks and
created the program by which there is
sweeping
in the in the exact same program so I
don't understand how that can be an
unconstitutional taking
thank you for the question uh one of the
new reps I understand was with
wheelabrader at one time is a very
famous federal law case with
wheelabrader about Rex wrecks are not
the property they are the certificate
renewable attributes are created at the
moment of Generation by the generator
those attributes are being taken by the
state under this program the state
follow-up
so if you have a solar array on your on
your home or in your yard and you don't
apply for the wrecks you are still
getting the value of the solar
generation for your property whether or
not you
apply for the Rex or sell the Rex you
still get the power
okay first of all the important point is
it's the registering of the Rex the
registering can cost thousands of
dollars the burdensome
series of things you have to do
particularly the electric socket getting
the electrician in all those things are
costs which you're saying to protect my
property I have to go through this
burdensome process I have to spend
thousands of dollars so that the state
won't take my property and give it to
private corporations and the utilities
that is an unfounded statement and I'm
sorry there was a second part to that
question
the no the print the principal part is
if you have the array you are getting
the solar power
run your home or run your business the
um when the state runs this formula to
apply the Rex to those who shouldn't be
getting them they take your entire
generation even the generation that you
used in your house you did not use
renewable energy because it was taken
from you you used null electricity
legally you did not have title you
cannot claim that your house or your
business is renewable energy powered
because it isn't someone else has taken
the legal claim
to that renewable attribute which is the
essential property right of renewable
energy
a company that that runs its facility
entirely on the basis of coal if they
buy enough wrecks they can say we use
renewable energy we're renewably powered
because they are the legal owners of the
renewable attributes
thank you I think we're going to move on
here thank you for Testimony uh The
Honorable Lee oxnaham and I'm sure that
the next testifier can perhaps shed some
light on the previous testimonies uh to
the the pros and cons so I have one more
I have one last speaker here if anyone
wants to
comment on what was said so far
particularly involving the utilities
please have a pink card come up to me so
right now I'll call on uh Mr Griffin
Roberts from Department of energy for
his testimony
foreign
before we begin again uh for both
testimony and answers to questions
please directly answer the question and
try to refrain from going a little bit
further off Target if it doesn't apply
directly to the question thank you
uh thank you uh representative Thomas
members of the committee for the record
Griffin Roberge stanji program manager
at the New Hampshire Department of
energy what I passed around a few
moments ago was just a three-page
outline of how the RPS functions I
figured that might be relevant for all
of the RPS related bills that we're
going to be discussing today
um I do apologize for the second page it
is upside down
um uh it came out of the printer
incorrectly this morning uh so please
bear with me on that but um I figured
I'd share that just as a reference point
for a lot of the RPS bills that we'll be
discussing today
circling back
um to this bill House Bill 234 the New
Hampshire Department of energy is
neutral on the bill as introduced as has
been mentioned uh the bill repeals a
statutory provision in the RPS statute
allowing for a credit uh against an
electric suppliers RPS obligation under
class one and two for customer cited
sources that are net metered and for
which renewable energy credits have not
been issued
um
just for background
um I do want to point uh the committee
to a statutorily mandated review of the
RPS that last occurred in 2018.
um this credit mechanism was actively
discussed uh during that time through a
collaborative stakeholder engagement
process uh held at the puc when they
manage the program in that review there
was no consensus among stakeholders on
the future of this crediting mechanism
some argued in favor of retaining the
credit as it reduces overall cost of RPS
compliance to ratepayers and to electric
suppliers others felt that the credit
should be eliminated to increase the
market for class II renewable energy
credits at that time in 2018 the puc
agreed that the credit is a reasonable
policy to retain because it recognizes
the renewable attributes of all eligible
solar PV cited facilities in New
Hampshire including those that are not
currently certified to produce wrecks
additionally because these net metered
facilities for which the credit is being
claimed likely received financial
support from the state's renewable
energy fund under the RPS the energy
generated from those facilities should
contribute to the state's overall RPS
goals so in that context the passage of
the bill
um would likely prevent net Merit
facilities who received ref financial
support from contributing to the state's
RPS goals the crediting mechanism and
statute is meant to capture those
facilities that aren't Rec certified and
without the credit they do not unless
they become recertified on their own
um in the in the review the puc
concluded that the capacity factor used
for the class II credit was too high at
the time it was 20 percent they felt
that that capacity factor for certain so
for solar facilities was too high and a
little bit off of uh realistic data so
they did recommend amending statute to
reduce that capacity factor from 20
percent to 14 which is more in line with
uh with historical data for these for
these uh for these systems that
amendment was made in 2021 through House
Bill 309 which reduced the capacity
factor from 20 percent to a capacity
Factor equal to isonial England's annual
PV energy forecast this changed just
occurred in 2001 and a little bit of a
little bit as shown in the past
compliance here so that change has
modestly increased the amount of wrecks
that electric suppliers must procure
underclass 2 but again I do want to
emphasize that it is modest
um that really concludes my testimony on
this bill and I'm happy to take any
thank you for your testimony I will call
on representative Summers for a question
thank you Mr chairman
um and thank you for taking my question
this is a question I have and it's been
bewildering to me so I'm going to try to
make make it very brief but uh
my constituents I know are right now are
paying in my area paying around 25 27
cents per kilowatt and we've heard
multiple bills about increasing rates
for their supposed benefit now speaking
directly to this bill how much would the
rates of our my constituents go up if
this was passed thank you for the
question so I'll try to unpack that a
little bit and feel free to stop me or
cut me off if I'm if I'm going off the
rails so
um to back up the credit mechanism is
used as a way to capture uh net metered
facilities in the state that are not
currently certified to produce wrecks so
if you guys
um were to look at page two of the
um of the hand that I provided you'll
see on the right hand side that in order
to become certified to produce wrecks
you need to Mr
um excuse me please I'm I'm terribly
sorry I need to make an announcement
there is a policy in this room to have
no signs uh in this room so with the
visitor that's here please
put her sign outside in the hallway if
if you would please we have a policy of
those signs
please it is a policy
I understand
please put your sign outside
if you wish to testify you can fill out
thank you thank you Mr chair so I'm
sorry for the interruption please
continue so um
in order to create renewable energy
credits uh Facility Owners need to be
registered in order to do so and to do
so you must uh work with a independent
monitor or a Rec aggregator who can
measure the output of your facility to
that would then generate Rex and then
you were actually producing Rex if you
are not certified to do that you're not
producing wrecks the way the credit
mechanism is meant to function is that
it's meant to capture those who are
currently net mirrored not rec certified
but likely received support from the
state's renewable energy fund under the
RPS to capture the uh to capture the
output that those facilities made the
light the anticipated wrecks that they
would have likely created and and could
and make sure that those wrecks
contribute to the state's overall RPS
goals repealing the credit would
potentially allow some who receive
support from the renewable energy fund
to walk away and not have any means of
actually crediting their output to the
state's RPS goals that's one your
question regarding impact to ratepayers
repealing this credit would likely
increase the need for electric suppliers
such as eversource such as consolation
so those folks to procure Class 2 rex
that would likely uh lead to an
indeterminable increase in RPS
compliance costs as folks need to as
electric suppliers need to procure
additional Wrecks for that category but
on the on the on the other side is that
is there an argument to be made about
solar facilities reducing a state's
transmission costs and that type of
thing there is an argument to be made
there as well
thank you uh in the interest of time I
will take one more question from
representative munz please before we
move on to our next uh thank you Mr
chair and thank you again for coming in
um just wanted to follow up on that last
comment you made about the process of
um certifying Rex
um if someone has not taken the time
effort to get their their their
um
but their certificate certified
how then is it how then can that can the
value of that energy
be used by a utility to to fulfill their
Rec requirement if it's not a certified
wreck uh thank you for the question
um I think the answer would be that this
credit mechanism does that is that it is
meant to capture those facilities that
maybe aren't Rec certified and as we
heard today there are certainly hurdles
for smaller systems to get Rec certified
and produce those wrecks I'm not
doubting that
um but the crediting mechanism is a way
to capture those facilities that are to
capture those facilities that maybe ha
don't want to incur the burden of
becoming Rec certified capture the
potential output from those facilities
credit them to the state's RPS
um RPS goals in a way make sure they're
contributing to the state's renewable
energy policies without the credit you
could potentially have folks out there
who you know are you know have solar PVC
facilities net metering facilities but
there isn't a way to capture any
anticipated wrecks that they may have
created if they were Rec certified
hopefully that makes sense but more than
willing to unpack that if need be thank
you uh if you will a quick follow-up if
it only if it's a quick answer
well um we'll see
I I guess I want to come back to the the
comments that we heard from the the last
presenter is that so how is that not a
taking of personal property I thank you
for the question I am certainly not a
lawyer I am not going to pretend to be
one so I know that there was some
earlier discussion about
unconstitutional taking and that type of
thing I don't want to necessarily get
into that because I know I'm not going
to be well versed in it
um but I think my answer would be that
the crediting mechanism in statute which
it was created back in 2010 I'm sorry
um has been in existence for some time
I'm not aware of any Constitution any
any type of unconstitutional claims
being made in the court or anything like
that
um it's just what's currently in statue
in the legislature has mandated thank
you for your testimony uh
Mr robersh and your answer to the
questions I'd like to move on please to
our next testifier Mr locata from
eversource
I'm sure we'll have some more questions
here as well in the interest of time
good morning Michael Licata representing
eversource energy
um ever sources is neutral on the bill
this is truly a public policy decision
that the legislature uh makes but
um if folks have any questions I am
happy to either do my best to answer
them now or take them back and try to
provide an answer at a future date
well I think uh
as a chair I will ask a question in
previous years when this bill has come
up uh we have learned from eversource
that it would increase the residence
electric bill
is that
still true if if this bill were to pass
would people's residents electric bills
increase and why
so that is correct
um so unused wrecks that are
used wrecks that are not used by the
system owner are used to reduce the
utilities RPS compliance obligations
which reduces the number of renewable
energy credits that the utility has to
purchase
thereby reducing the cost of compliance
with the RPS
if those unused wrecks were not allowed
to be used by the utility it would
increase the number of wrecks the
utility would have to purchase
increasing the compliance costs with the
RPS
as my follow-up does that mean when you
say it will increase your costs does
that mean that that being a cost of
business would be folded into your next
rate hike request
yes the cost of the RPS compliance are
included in the Energy Service cost uh
so that is a direct pass-through to
uh Colin representative partial
yes sure thank you for my question and
thank you for being here today
um one thing which I've heard several
times here and I wonder if you can
enlighten me on this
by avoiding the cost of a compliance
and not having to meet that standard
you're saying these savings are passed
on consumers
are any savings passed on to
shareholders as well now and how can you
be sure of that I'm sorry follow up
and can you tell me the process by
that's uh you can certainly yeah our RPS
compliance costs are strictly regulated
by the Public Utilities Commission the
reduction in the compliance the number
of wrecks that the utility has to
purchase
um is actually comes from the Public
Utilities Commission I think now the
department of energy since the
separation so uh the calculation on the
reduction is actually done by a state
agency and then that number is provided
to the utility to say You must purchase
X number of wrecks to be compliant so
the utility
as with default service it is a a
pass-through
I understand thank you so much
representative Bernardi has a question
thank you Mr chairman so
um
representative partial already uh zeroed
in on my subject matter the the we were
told that some of these wrecks are
bought by outside utilities but any
utility
buying a wreck or sweeping a wreck
it it would would go into the electric
generation cost of the utility that is
passed it's a direct pass-through to the
customer so if they swept the rep it's
going to be a reduction in the rate to
the customer is that not true so
I can only speak for
regulated distribution utilities and how
we comply with our RPS obligations
I cannot speak to third-party
competitive suppliers that were
referenced
how they use those wrecks and how it
impacts their costs so I can really only
speak to how eversource as a rate
regulated
distribution utility whose
charges and rates are are scrutinized
and approved by the Public Utilities
Commission so I I can't speak to third
so this would also apply just follow up
sorry this would apply to Unitil and uh
and Liberty and all the the utilities of
New Hampshire treated the same way with
respect to wreck sweeping Unitil Liberty
and the co-op yeah are all responsible
to comply with the RPS thank you so
bottom line we're eliminating
rate payer costs by allowing utilities
to sweep these wrecks
correct
representative munz has a question thank
you Mr chair
um in the um testimony that the uh the
bill sponsor provided she gave us a
handout that references the eversource
rec meter socket requirement
um can you explain what that is and how
that works I I'm afraid I I I'm not
familiar with the handout but I would be
happy to take a copy and provide a
response
okay thank you
representative closure has a question uh
thank you chair thank you Mr Lakota
taking my question
um
I'll let you finish taking you no no
please
concerning the meters an owner has to
get a special sounds like a costly meter
and you had mentioned uh
that this the sweeping or the utilities
measures a potential
um Rex because there's no meter how does
um the utilities
determine how much is produced in
attributes to add up to a wreck
uh so
if I'm understanding the question I
apologize if I'm not
this program applies to net metering
customers who participate in net
metering and so we do track their their
usage and their production and that is
uh thank you profile uh thank you Mr La
Carta I had forgotten that one part of
it
representative Noel has a question
thank you Mr chairman uh thank you for
taking my question uh in in having to
pay uh alternative compliance payments
uh you're you're obviously increasing
your costs does that increase costs have
a one-to-one relationship to your rates
or is there a specific formula as to how
that gets distributed into the rates
um so the first point I'd like to make
is
um the utilities and I think I I can I
think this is true of all the utilities
um very much try to purchase Rex as
opposed to Alternative compliance
payments
um that is our our goal not to just pay
into a fund but rather to
ensure that the RPS is functioning the
way that it's intended to which is to
incent the development
um of renewable generation or preserve
existing I think the question though
whether it's rex or or alternative
compliance payments whether that's one
to one it is a direct pass-through our
compliance costs are directly paid by uh
customers
representative Wendy Thomas asked a
question thank you Mr chair
um just trying to get a number here um
in 2021 eversource made a profit of 1.2
billion do you have the numbers for 2022
any follow-up no I'm sorry okay
representative munz has a question this
will be the last question for this
public hearing thanks Mr chair
um
when we when we talk about uh rates
while there may be a short-term impact
on rates isn't it true that money that
um
you may have to pay into the alternate
you know for alternative compliance
payments that goes into the renewable
energy fund and that that has a longer
term positive benefit on rates
um so
the way that the RPS is intended to
function is the utilities and I I keep
saying the utilities but it really is uh
suppliers of electricity which include
utilities and and third parties
um have specific percentage obligations
to purchase renewable energy credits and
when they are unable to do so
the program essentially has a financial
cap called the alternative compliance
payment and that does go into the fund
the way the program is intended to
function is those alternative compliance
payments then incent the development
through rebates of renewable generation
which provides a source of Rex to avoid
the supplier of energy from having to
purchase an alternate make an
alternative compliance payment in the
future so there's sort of a virtuous
cycle there to try to increase increased
demand so uh to It's a Long Way of of
trying to answer the question to say
alternative compliment compliance
payments that go into the renewable
energy fund if they function the way
that they're intended to should create a
supply of wrecks for the utilities and
suppliers to purchase in the future
avoiding the necessity of purchasing of
making alternative compliance payments
in future years
okay thank you Mr locata for your
testimony and with that I'm going to
close the public hearing on House Bill
and since we're already a little bit
late I'm gonna open a public hearing
after we hear about the blue sheet for
this bill House Bill 234
Mr representative closure could you give
us the the statistics uh thank you chair
House Bill 234
the blue sheet was three in favor
none opposed online was 117 in favor for
a post
thank you and I just remind members that
that online number is a snapshot of what
the situation was at about nine o'clock
this morning and it could change
substantially by midnight tonight
so with that we'll open the public
hearing for House Bill 246 which is
relative to the uses of monies in the
renewable energy fund and I'll call
first to the stand the sponsor of this
legislation representative Janine notter
chairman and good morning members of the
committee
so
before I begin my testimony just one to
start by defining RPS RPS is
the renewable portfolio standard which
is a set of laws requiring Electric
utilities to buy Power from solar and
wind producers at higher prices than
charged by fossil fuel producers of
electricity
so this bill is pretty straightforward
right now utilities by renewable energy
certificates called Rex to meet their
renewable portfolio standard RPS
obligations or they pay alternative
compliance payments acps for example
many of the state's competitive
suppliers of electricity purchase acps
instead of Rex to avoid the
administrative expense of purchasing
wrecks
acps go into the renewable energy fund
ref
those payments then go out as subsidies
for solar arrays wood stove
installations and other non-residential
renewable energy projects located in New
Hampshire
for example one such project replaced
two turbines and three valves boosting
capacity to 0.44 megawatts at one
hydroelectric facility
this bill would rebate those ref dollars
back to the rate payers employing the
same mechanism that the Public Utilities
Commission uses to rebate Reggie
proceeds back to rate payers Regional
greenhouse gas initiative it would be
uniform across the board on a per
kilowatt basis these rebates would lower
the cost of electricity for the state's
rate payers
as written this change would be
permanent I plan to offer an amendment
to make this change temporary for a
two-year period
I will it will have wording along the
lines of within 60 days of Passage it
will require the puc to start the
proceedings to deter determine how to
distribute ref Monies to ratepayers
if you look at the website for the
Department of energy you can read the
RPS energy fund annual report dated
October 1st 2022.
scrolling down to table 2 you will find
the acp's revenues by compliance year
for 2021 the total was just over 7
million dollars
with this bill that amount would be
given back to the rate payers even this
modest change will help struggling
families who can afford who can't afford
to buy eggs or gas up the car their car
these days and it will help to chip away
at all the different taxes and fees that
are taken from them and redistributed
elsewhere
and I have a constituent down the hall
that I I need to go support on another
bill so I'm not going to be taking
questions so I will leave them for the
people testifying behind me thank you
thank you representative for Testimony
oh representative
bye
thank you Mr chair and thank you members
of the committee it's nice to see you
from this angle
um for the record my name is
representative Chris muns I serve as one
of the four representatives from
Rockingham County District 29 which
includes Hampton
I'm speaking in opposition to HB 246 FN
I prepared a handout for you that is
going around the table right now but I'd
like to just give you a quick overview
of what it includes
according to the Department of energy
there is currently about 9.6 million
dollars in the renewable energy fund
about 1.8 million of that is already
earmarked for future expenses so that
would leave about 7.8 million to be
available to offset rates if this bill
passed
the department of energy reports that we
currently consume about 10.7 billion
kilowatt hours of electricity at that
level of consumption the 7.8 million in
the renewable energy fund would
translate into a one-time available rate
adjustment of
0.072 cents
per kilowatt hour or about 10.54 cents
per customer per year
for one year
furthermore assuming the fiscal notes
estimate that 4.6 million is added to
the renewable energy fund every year is
correct going forward if these are also
available to offset rates that would
result in an additional cost reduction
of
0.043 cents per kilowatt hour or six
dollars and 25 cents per customer per
year
so at most the benefit to customers
would be
16.70 79 cents in the first year and six
dollars and 25 cents per year thereafter
compare compare that to what we have
already been able to do with the
renewable energy fund the department of
energy reports that between fiscal year
18 and fiscal year 22 a total of 20.1
million dollars of renewable energy
funds has been invested in over 4 000
different projects which have created
177 million dollars of total economic
activity creating jobs General and
generating important and needed revenue
for our towns counties and the state
itself
most importantly those Investments have
helped to diversify our energy sector
help to offset additional rate increases
and better preparers for the future
additional opportunities for
diversification and economic growth will
be lost if HB 246 passes
all of that for a small investment of
about six dollars and 25 cents per year
in our future by every electric consumer
in New Hampshire
finally since the FY since FY 18 the
renewable energy fund has covered 2.6
million in in Department of energy
administrative costs costs that would
have been would have to be funded from
the general fund if all proceeds from
the renewable energy fund are rebated
for all those reasons I urge you to vote
this bill is in expedient to legislate
and I'm happy to try to answer any
thank you representative I hope we
looked okay from your Vantage Point much
better from this angle
good to hear good to hear thank you
representative Harrington has a question
for you thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question you know over
the last couple of days we've heard
people talking in the various hearings
here as well as we see it all over the
news uh basically all the time from the
the so-called inflation reduction act uh
why there's tens of billions of dollars
out there for renewable energy projects
literally we're throwing huge amounts of
money at these on the federal level uh I
question as to whether we even have the
resources to spend it all but wouldn't
it be prudent to turn around and say
since we're getting all these massive
subsidies from the federal government
through our tax dollars there that it
would be time to cut back on some of the
subsidies for renewable energy here
because we probably just can't spend it
all
foreign
I don't think we have any choice but
trying to figure out a way to spend it
all and
um I I
believe and trust in the people of New
Hampshire that they understand and
realize that we do need to diversify
everybody that I talked to when I was
campaigning for this position
um they they talked about you know the
high cost of energy
and you know that is something that we
need to address but the people of New
Hampshire are
um very intelligent and they understand
that if you put all your eggs in one
basket such as we we have done with
natural gas
um you are going to be at the mercy of
the market and we need to diversify
follow up follow up uh yeah in your
handout you talk about how uh all this
uh subsidies for renewable energy
created 177 million dollars of total
economic activity did you do a
calculation of how much economic
activity would be
um created if all the individual rate
payers got to save got to have their 16
dollars and 79 cents and there's six
dollars and 25 cents obviously we're
tracking thousands and thousands of
people with that money spending it as
they see fit rather than the government
does wouldn't that create at least as
much economic activity or do you believe
um I don't know that I can really answer
that because that wasn't the question I
asked the department of energy I asked
the department of energy to tell me what
you know money has been invested and
what did what the benefit was I mean but
you would excuse me follow up
all right a quick one we're not here to
debate okay uh okay people who are
sitting at the testimony table
thank you representative muns any
further questions I guess representative
Wendy Thomas has a question thank you Mr
chair
um
the the rebate program is used wildly by
municipalities if it were removed and
they no longer got rebates would that
affect taxes
town taxes city taxes thank you
um again I I haven't done a detailed
deep dive and Analysis on that but that
would make sense that if you take money
away from a municipality that they have
to make that up somewhere and the way
they make it up is through increased
representative parcel has a question
thank you chair of Olson thank you for
your testimony
our former person that testified stated
that
Renewables are more expensive than
fossil fuels and as she's not available
to ask this question I would like to ask
you are you aware of any numbers that
saving rules are actually more expensive
than fossil fuels
I am not aware of any numbers and um
so yeah that I would I'd have to answer
it that way I mean my my understanding
is that as we invest more in renewable
energy production costs are coming down
um and everything that I have read
anecdotally suggests that for example
the cost of solar power is much cheaper
now than it's ever been and I also know
from what I read that you know the price
of natural gas which we are almost
wholly dependent on has been going up
pretty dramatically and as a result of
the fact that we're so dependent on it
we are very much susceptible to the the
whims of the market
thank you representative Bernardi has a
question
yes directly to what representative
partial has
asked about do you recall the iso New
England presentation where they made the
statement that when you you uh build out
Renewables they are not reliable enough
therefore you need backup power
that is reliable whether it be nuclear
or or gas or whatever in order to ensure
that you can meet the demand
that the customers have
hence cost of Renewables are more
well I I guess I guess I would argue
that as as a as a demand for power
increases over the coming years
we should be able to rely on the
existing fossil fuel in uh generating
infrastructure that we have to provide
that Baseline capacity if we invest you
know in if the new money we invest is in
Renewables
so I know okay let's let's not engage in
debate remember executive session is the
time to engage in debate just trying to
answer the question uh I think you did
answer the question so thank you
representative closure has a question
and remember we're not here to debate
we'll save that for executive session
thank you for a reminder
chair
thank you representative Muntz taking my
question sure we hear about
the money's being returned money should
be used for portfolio renewable
portfolio because
it's property
value of the customer do you see a way
to have an opt-in that the customer
receives their rebate and they can opt
in
to transfer that to the fund
thank you no I I I don't and I and I
think someone
mentioned this
um last week or so
um
um you don't you don't opt in to Fire
Protection Services
um it's something that we as a community
decide is important to all of us and
um we all agree that we're going to fund
it and I would say that investing in our
future
um and and being able to provide you
know reliable energy to Future
Generations is something that we as a
community have decided that we're going
to do and we should need and we should
okay I have a question for you thank you
for providing this information from the
Department of energy a lot of
statistical information here
and I haven't a chance to had a chance
to review it thoroughly yet because I
just received it a few minutes ago but
since you probably have reviewed it
thoroughly can you tell me
if these numbers show that the projects
that are funded by the renewable energy
fund have reduced the cost of
electricity in New Hampshire
that was the one question I didn't want
to hear
reluctantly no it I I don't have that
information
and I would like to get that information
I I think your question is very valid
and it would be nice if we could if we
could have that information
okay thank you representative Reynolds
has a question thank you Mr chairman um
but
however along the lines of
Representative Bernardi's question and
you direct follow-up to Chairman voz's
question do you remember
the testimony the presentation we had
from ISO New England which showed that
efficiency and distributed generation
distributed solar
throughout New England had resulted in a
very significant measurable
reduction in demand
throughout the regional
electric power pool and wouldn't
maintaining New Hampshire's
renewable energy fund and contributing
continuing to support distributed
generation in New Hampshire
reduce electric costs for all consumers
you don't have to answer that question
representative munzett falls into the
category of debate we don't allow would
you believe or do you agree kind of
questions do you remember as that falls
into that category so one if I if I can
move on if I may just one file that was
representative Bernardi's question so I
thought I could uh do the same
what one one I don't recall his question
being of that nature but one one just
quick follow-up to to your question
chairman Vos I mean I I do think it
would be one of the things if it doesn't
already exist it would be very
worthwhile for all of us and everyone in
the state if there was a mechanism to
track you know what the impact is on of
of any any action that we're taking in
the energy field on on rates and and
there may that may exist and I just
haven't stumbled upon it yet but that
would be something very valuable I think
if you do stumble upon it please let us
know
foreign
and I will now call on our next
presenter
and call to the table The Honorable Lee
oxenham
who will be testifying for herself
former member of this committee and a
good friend welcome
don't forget to turn on the mic
thank you very much chairman Bose Lee
rather than provide the prepared
testimony I would like to take the
opportunity to use my two minutes
possibly to better Advantage by
answering a couple of the questions that
have come up
the iso chart demonstrates that
renewable energy and Energy Efficiency
have made great strides measurable
strides in reducing the total demand the
total load on the grid system and that
is in the millions of dollars of the
renewable energy fund report it shows
these numbers the data is there
sixteen dollars per year or six dollars
per year as a rebate
is less than a dollar a month no one is
investing those funds no one is
assisting in the energy transformation
by having six dollars or sixteen dollars
or sixty or six hundred dollars these
are these are projects that take large
amounts of money
um
assisting the clean energy transition
and assessing the value
positive value of renewable energy is
if I may quote
um
from from my testimony RSA 362 F1 States
quoted is therefore in the public
interest to stimulate investment in low
emission renewable energy generation
Technologies in New England and in
particular in New Hampshire
if I could just switch out of New
Hampshire for a moment when they had the
terrible winter cold in Texas last year
the natural gas pipelines froze it was
demand response it was Energy Efficiency
and it was Renewables that kept as much
of the Electric System going as possible
the Christmas of this past year was a
terrible time in the South where they
had blackouts in pjm they had they were
on the verge of rolling blackouts but
again
using the resources of Energy Efficiency
renewable energy and demand response
they were able to avoid that these are
tremendous values and finally I'll
simply say if we are taking the critical
crisis of our time climate the climate
crisis if we take that into account we
must be putting the maximum amount of
investment into into managing what we
can mitigate today so that we do not
face a disaster in the future from being
concerned about six cents or 16 cents on
thank you you actually uh stayed below
two minutes I I was surprised well done
so do we have questions for
representative former representative
oxenham I have one
do you think that
in these inflationary times that we're
living in that
people who live paycheck to paycheck
deserve some relief
from their
from the high cost of electricity and
the high cost of heating their house do
you think people deserve any relief
I think people deserve relief on their
housing I think they deserve relief on
their groceries I think we I think
people the low-income uh of end of the
latter deserve help from people who have
higher incomes and that's why I believe
in an income tax which I I don't believe
many um present here would would accept
and if I could I'm sorry that's not this
did you have to this bill but go ahead
um no the subject to this bill is the
renewable energy fund and if I could
just hearken back to a question that
came up previously the issue of the
rebates this fig leaf that the rebates
are the way that people who profited by
the renewable energy fund rebate can pay
back into it the RPS requires
the Pavements from the electricity
suppliers not from people who got
rebates and in fact thousands of those
who received a rebate never
um I'm sorry I do better if I read it
thousands of those subject to the taking
never received any rebate and thousands
of those who did receive a rebate are
not subject to the taking so that are
that argument comes up again and again
it came up three years ago when this
legislation passed the legislature and
was unfortunately vetoed by the governor
that uh this this this is this bill
wants to eliminate the renewable energy
fund wants to eliminate
a very important source of investment
that is of Great Value to all New
Hampshire residents no matter what their
income level is
representative partial has a question
making sure Volson it's good to see you
today nice to see you
we earlier the saw uh session we uh
voted in a bipartisan way for house HCB
2023 I believe which uh which provided
rate payer relief directly through a
mechanism that was very well spelled out
do you believe that's in a more
appropriate way to provide rate payer
relief than something like this
I certainly do and thank you for the
question
okay seeing no further questions we
thank you for being here
former representative Lee oxenham all
right next up
we have
the department of energy and Griffin
Roberge to testify on this bill Mr
robarsh
thank you chairman Vos members of the
committee uh for the record new uh oh
Griffin Rober CNG program manager at the
New Hampshire Department of energy
um here to testify
um in a neutral position on House Bill
for uh 246.
um Department did want to note the
Bill's impacts uh should it become law
um
obviously we'll be discussing the RPS
quite a bit today and various pieces of
legislation so to back up RSA 362f which
was enacted in 2007
established the state's renewable
portfolio standard the RPS established
four different classes of renewable
energy resources like hydroelectric
biomass methane geothermal solar wind
Etc
under the RPS electric suppliers such as
eversource your default utility
suppliers or constellation a third-party
electric supplier must obtain renewable
energy credits for each of the four
classes under the erps as a set
percentage of their retail electric load
a lot of this is specified in the
handout that I provided earlier one Rec
represents the renewable energy
attributes of one megawatt hour of
electricity from that source
if electric suppliers cannot purchase
the necessary amount of wrecks needed to
satisfy their obligations under the the
four classes electric suppliers must
make alternative compliance payments
these payments are made directly to the
department and are deposited into a
dedicated fund under State Statute
called the renewable energy fund the
renewable energy fund is used to offer
rebates and competitive grants to
advance the deployment of renewable
energy projects that can create wrecks
to help electric suppliers satisfy their
RPS obligations the ideas be the idea
behind the RPS is that acps are
collected into the ref they're then used
to encourage the development of Rec
eligible renewable energy projects that
can produce as I said needed Rex to be
bought and used by electric suppliers to
meet their RPS obligations much of this
is in that diagram on page six of that
handout that flow chart
which kind of maps out how the RPS works
uh turning to the actual uh bill the
bill really impacts if you look at the
flow chart the green bubble labeled the
renewable energy fund and largely the
bubble next to it that's labeled uh new
certified facility so that bottom tier
of the flow chart so under section one
the ref is not repealed but repurposed
it doesn't alter State expenditures from
the fund but how the fund uh expends
dollars in that fund So in theory under
under this new paradigm that the bill
presents is that acps will still be
collected from electric suppliers they
will then be deposited into the
renewable energy fund however as is
proposed as is outlined in the flow
chart
the ability to draw admin costs offer
rebate and Grant programs for residents
and commercial industrial uh users is no
longer in existence those programs are
repealed under this bill and all of the
dollars that flow into the RAF for now
rebated back to Electric customers via
puc likely a puc adjudicated process to
bring forward a reduction in electric
rates
um
I think what the department wants to
note is that in the bill as it is
currently drafted and I haven't seen the
amendment that representative naughter
mentioned that she was proposing but
language in the bill removes the ability
from the Department for the Department
to draw administrative expenses from the
renewable energy fund these
administrative expenses run the gamut so
it includes managing the various rebate
and Grant programs working on our PS
related dockets administrative rule
changes monitoring and valid and
validating facility and supplier
compliance with the RPS potential
program revisions and without the ref
funding uh to be quite Frank doe would
be unable to implement or continue to
maintain the state's RPS policy as it's
been imposed by the New Hampshire
General Court
absent a dedicated funding source doe
would not have the financial means to
maintain its current administrative
resources for the RPS for the
foreseeable future and would likely need
an alternative dedicated funding source
to do do that that's section one section
two of the bill repeals the stat the
various statutory Provisions
establishing the Grant and rebate
programs that the ref uses dollars to
fund
um beyond the repeat just the simple
repeal of those programs section two
would likely impact pending rebate and
Grant applications before uh the
department it would likely affect
ongoing our our requests for proposals
or rfps for refunded programs and
current Grant award contracts that have
been approved uh by governor and Council
for current awardees to these programs
by way of context the department manages
four different rebate programs there is
one for residential solar one for
residential wood pellet systems and then
two for commercial industrial users for
Solar Technologies rebate and a wood
pellet furnace or boiler rebate
and then the the other two Grant
programs include the non-residential
competitive grant program and the LMI
Community solar grant program
um the non-residential competitive grant
program has been utilized largely by
commercial and Industrial customers such
as municipalities or large businesses
for larger Renewable Energy Products
that can projects that can produce
wrecks that can then be used by electric
suppliers and then obviously as I'm sure
this committee is is aware of the LMI
Community solar grant program is used to
provide grants for
Community solar projects that would
directly provide a benefit to low to
moderate income households on their bill
and then further information I guess on
the bill can be found in our in the
Department's fiscal note but beyond that
um if you happen to take any questions
that the committee might have
thank you very much for
that valuable information so if I
understand you correctly
you are saying that
section two of the bill the repeal of
362 F colon 10 5 through 11 is the
problematic section of the bill and if
that was removed from the bill
you would see that there would be fewer
issues with the bill is that my
understanding thank you for the question
I think uh obviously it's a politics
policy decision for legislators to make
as to how the fund is uh functions
obviously we just follow what's
prescribed in State Statute I think
I think the more concerning aspect of
the bill is the removal of the ability
of the department to drag admit to draw
administrative expenses from the fund
without that
um the RPS currently in statute
um kind of caps out at 2025 so there's
still two years here of potential
increased obligations across the classes
there's processes that need to take
place to make sure that systems are
certified certified to create wrecks
without the ability to pay for staff to
do that the RPS is more or less just in
statute without any
State staff or agencies kind of managing
it or overseeing it it's just acting on
its own
excellent thank you for that
clarification representative
Corman has a question thank you Mr
chairman and thank you Mr Roberts for
taking my question you've just listed
several problems that would arise if
this bill were to pass yet you state
that Doe is neutral on it so what are
the advantages that could possibly
counterbalance all these disadvantages
well I thank you for the question
representative um as has been mentioned
uh you know
there this is a time of historic um
electric rates and that type of thing
um you know whether or not let uh
policymakers such as yourself determine
that this is the best way to provide
um a policy mechanism to provide a rate
relief to Electric customers that
something for folks to consider as a
department of energy as a legislative
legislature created us it's to provide a
unified Direction on state energy
policies and obviously provide the
legislators feedback on you know the
implications or benefits of any type of
policy decision they make that's at
least the indicate that's at least the
thank you okay seeing no further
questions we'd like to thank you for
your
testimony and participation and now I'd
like to call forward uh Mr Greg Moore
representing Americans for Prosperity to
give us his take on this bill
good morning Mr Moore
good morning Mr chairman members of
science technology and energy committee
always great to be before this committee
uh so
I'm here today uh in support of House
Bill 246 representative NATA reached out
uh I think part of it because in 2012
when I was working as a chief of staff
of the house I did a lot of work on the
bill that rebated the Reggie
back then and she of course was still on
this committee at the time so uh this is
a very similar mechanism presumably if
the legislature wishes to move forward
obviously we're dealing the time that
has historic rate increases for
electricity just to quantify that for
for the committee I got an email from
one of my former electricity suppliers
it said new low rate and I opened it up
and it said 1677 a kilowatt which kind
of struck me because a little over a
year and a half ago I had re-upped knock
on wood with a three-year plan at eight
and a half cents a kilowatt but that
should indicate just the type of
escalation we've seen in electricity
prices just over the Arc of the last
year
uh how do we get relief to the
ratepayers I know that there are a
number of ways a number of mechanisms uh
one of them that the governor proposed
last year which was to use Surplus
revenues to do 100 it was 150 dollar
credits uh via the utilities I know the
legislature decided to go in a different
direction
decided to uh to go with expanding
eligibility for LIHEAP so they so it was
a different direction as far as
providing energy rate relief but steps
like these are important at a time when
we're seeing just doubling of
electricity costs and take taking the
opportunity to move forward with this is
is critical now finding the long-term
solutions to
resolve a number of the issues that are
facing facing us as far as finding
affordable long-term Energy Solutions
everybody has their own opinions whether
it's increasing natural gas pipeline
capacity whether it's expanding nuclear
which would be my choice but uh or the
government is back to large-scale hydro
or even waiting for technological
advances for existing Renewables to
improve to improve overall overall
affordability we need to take steps at
least in the short term and I and I I'm
encouraged that representative said you
know let's let's do this for a two-year
cycle I think that's appropriate
considering the rate relief I mean we
don't know how long the situation in
Europe is going to continue
so we think it's uh practical to take
steps like this following procedures
like we did back in 2012 and continuing
on efforts to try to try to advance some
rate payer relief at this this I think
it's it's
a difficult time for a lot of low low
income people and there are other
mechanisms certainly but I think this is
one and it's worth exploring and that's
why we support this legislation so I'd
thank you we appreciate you being here
I'll ask you a quick question to start
off
the mechanism proposed here would
probably take six eight months to get in
place do you think that provides relief
quickly enough to help
folks out there who are
trying to make it in a tough economy
well I don't expect that we see
electricity rates go down over the next
six to eight months I suspect that
that's yeah there's probably going to
see a leveling of those costs so whether
they get that relief now or in six
months I think they'll it'll still be
just as needed I think we saw it a
little bit faster than that in 2012 when
we when we did the uh and I understand
how the dockets move into puc it doesn't
happen overnight nothing happens
overnight particularly with energy
nothing happens overnight but uh but to
your point I don't see it uh any
near-term reductions in electricity
costs I don't think any of the any of
the changes we've seen uh will have made
much much of an impact in six or eight
months so I think that
rate relief in six to eight months would
be just as valuable as rate relief in
two months
great thank you
questions for uh representative Corman
has a question for you thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question a representative Munns
testified that the reduction per year
would be about six dollars and 25 cents
per customer do you really see make that
making a big difference I think for some
people yes representative I I think that
for some people who are maybe living on
the edge six dollars a year might make a
difference but I I think it's probably
uh up to them to make that decision
foreign
Harrington has a question thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question getting back to that figure the
question I had asked earlier about the
um that was in this handouts is that was
created 177 million dollars worth of
total economic activity now under this
bill rather than going to that it would
be returned to the rate payers could you
comment on what you think the rate pays
would do with this extra money
I think every rate payer would make
their own decision of what to do with it
uh as far as economic activity I I've
been around a long time in 20 years in
and around State politics and I got to
tell you there have been so many studies
that have promised some so much economic
activity and and what you find is you
really drill into it is that there are a
lot of assumptions that are making made
in each and every one of those studies
uh and none of them consider the
alternatives
and uh to your point it's a valuable
point from an economic perspective if
the money is not spent here would would
probably be spent somewhere else and
that would create other economic
activity so it's hard to quantify what
representative Wendy Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair
um in order to qualify for a rebate you
must demonstrate that the measure you're
putting forward saves
um it it it is energy efficient
um
so some some commercial
um clients
choose to put in an energy efficient
system even though it's a little more
expensive now they want to save money
down the road
um and that's then they get a rebate for
doing that if we removed these rebates
would these commercial clients still be
inclined to install energy efficient
equipment
thank you for the question
there's no there's no question that that
uh Capital Improvements were happening
before the renewable energy fund existed
so when people thought that there was a
long-term benefit by by making a capital
investment up front they would do it
it's not uncommon
um
is the incremental incentive enough to
make people make a major capital
investment I think that's an impossible
question to answer I I it's on a
representative Summers has a question
we have three more people who want to
testify so let's move on quickly thank
you Mr chairman uh just a very quick
question
um we've been talking this morning about
the ratepayers and how much they would
only you know 16 or six dollars per year
depending on which year
um and that it wouldn't go in effect for
six months but according to bill here it
does say that counties and
municipalities would recognize the
savings on this too is that correct
I don't know I I didn't I'm sorry I
didn't do the fiscal note so I really
couldn't speak to it okay thank you
there was a time when I did fiscal notes
okay see no further questions we want to
thank you for your testimony thank you
and call forward
Madeleine minnow and Heidi Kroll of the
good morning Mr chairman and members of
the committee um for the record my name
is Heidi Kroll I work at Gallagher
Callahan and gartrell and I'm here today
on behalf of the Granite State
hydropower Association which is a
voluntary non-profit trade Association
for the small scale Hydro industry here
in New Hampshire our Members Own and
operate nearly 50 Hydro facilities
located in 35 towns and cities
throughout New Hampshire totaling
approximately 55 megawatts of
distributed generation and with me today
is Madeleine minnow who works for Essex
Hydro is a member of the Granite State
hydropower Association and her role at
essex's Chief Operating Officer we are
opposed to the bill and I'll turn it
over to Madeline to explain our position
and then happy to answer any questions
thank you
um as Heidi stated gsha opposes this
bill
um though we certainly support rate
relief for New Hampshire Electric rate
payers we do not think that this would
provide meaningful relief for those rate
payers and it may actually end up
increasing certain costs
as you've heard already
um the way that the renewable portfolio
standard and the ref works is that all
electric suppliers have a compliance
obligation and they can either meet that
compliance obligation by purchasing
renewable energy certificates or making
alternative compliance payments the
alternative compliance payments is what
funds the renewable energy fund
purchasing renewable energy certificates
is a significantly lower cost and more
efficient way of meeting compliance
obligations because the ACP is a ceiling
price therefore Rex can always be
purchased
typically for significantly less than
the equivalent ACP in a given compliance
class
um every dollar that goes into the are
the ref then is spent on rebate and
Grant programs every dollar that is
spent from The Ref the intent is to
increase the supply of racks
with increasing supply of wrecks the
cost the value of Rex goes down and
therefore the cost of compliance for
electric suppliers goes down as you
heard the compliance cost is passed on
to ratepayers and so as we
have granted rebate programs that are
spent with the intent of increasing
supply of racks the compliance cost of
the RPS for rate payers should go down
we also Grant State hydropower
Association members have competed for
those competitive Grant programs and
have sometimes been successful this has
resulted in refurbished turbines that
were not no longer operational being put
back online and generating renewable
energy as well as new incremental
generation at existing projects that
also generate new bricks and renewable
energy
we also ran some numbers our numbers are
slightly different than representative
muns but I will share them with you so
ACB payments are variable year to year
in the last five years that's about
varied from a low of two and a half
million in 2019 to a high of 7.19
Million last year in 2021.
if that is rebated to rate pairs that
would be equivalent last year the high
amount in the last five years would be
0.068 cents per kilowatt hour
and so an average residential rate pair
that uses 600 kilowatt hours
would see a reduction of 41 cents on
their monthly bill so to put that into
context I live in Unitil territory if I
had used 600 kilowatt hours last month
in January my bill would be 218 dollars
and 20 cents if this bill were enacted
my bill would have instead bid
217.79 I can guarantee you that that
rate reduction would not be very
um as was already mentioned
um for the competitive grant program the
scoring is very much weighted to
encourage private investment
the dollars spent are typically matched
uh with 4.6 dollars on average of
private investment
as someone who runs a renewable energy
business I can tell you that grants that
will lower our return on investment when
we're looking at making a big investment
can make the difference between us
deciding to do a project or not do a
project
we're happy to take any questions okay
you guys asked for five minutes and you
have hit the four minute and 15 second
Mark so well done okay any questions for
Granite State hydropower representative
Corman has a question thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question so as I understand it you said
that
um
with the renewable energy fund that
actually helps create more renewable
energy which creates more wrecks and
therefore the supply of wrecks increases
therefore the price of Rex decreases
now you are representing people who
actually produce renewable energy so I'm
just curious why is it in your interest
for the price of wrecks to decrease so I
can tell you that when we model out
Investments we know that
renewable energy is going to continue to
develop so I can tell you that in our
financial models we assume a decreasing
value of Rex we know that this is going
to happen and so we factor that in we're
not trying to fight against that we
don't want to you know
poured wreck so that they are worth more
we we know that this is how the
renewable portfolio standard in every
New England state was designed is to
increase goals but at the same time have
mechanisms to increase the development
of renewable energy and to increase the
supply of racks with the goal that over
time
the supply will increase and so it's not
something we're trying to fight but I
can tell you that the grant programs
funded by The Ref are very beneficial to
to gsha members as I'm saying when we're
looking at making significant
Investments which may increase the
generation at some of our projects
having a grant like that is important to
us
okay seeing no further questions we
appreciate you being here and now we'll
call forward Meredith Hatfield
good uh morning
um chairman votes members of the
committee Meredith Hatfield for The
Nature Conservancy
we oppose this bill because we think
that both the RPS and the renewable
energy fund are important pieces of a
diversified portfolio approach to
meeting New Hampshire's energy needs and
I'm reminded of the discussions that you
had during your orientation about the
challenges with default service
um both the volatility and the price but
also the challenges with procuring it
and we think that investing in renewable
energy is an important part of
insulating our state from volatility
while also growing our clean energy
economy
people definitely need and deserve rate
relief and I think the state has already
taken significant steps to build on our
already very effective programs that are
administered through our community
action agencies but this bill you know
seems um
to not really make a dent in people's
energy bills and I would really
encourage the committee to think much
more about bills than rates and to think
about renewable programs as a way to
help us all reduce our bills I I wanted
to point you to the renewable energy
fund report that was issued by the
department of energy it's dated October
1st 2022
on page 30
the department says as this report
illustrates demand for rebates and Grant
Awards continues to be strong and
they're I believe they're referring to
the renewable energy fund rebate and
Grant funds have leveraged over 381
million dollars in private investment
boosting providing a boost to the
state's economy and creating jobs for
electricians plumbers and Alternative
Energy businesses
in addition there has been substantial
growth in distributed generation
renewable energy systems that serve to
diversify our energy Supply reduce our
Reliance on fossil fuels reduce
greenhouse gas emissions and increase
our energy Independence
I also wanted to make sure that you've
reviewed the fiscal note on the bill
it's been discussed by a few prior
speakers including the representative of
the department but the fiscal note does
indicate that County and local
governments would see their revenues
decline as grants from the renewable
energy fund would no longer be available
and I think anyone who pays property
taxes in the state understands that
state and local governments excuse me
local and County governments can can use
all the help that they can in reducing
things like their energy bills and
lastly I
would like to just amplify the comments
of the Department's representative about
the fact that they would no longer have
funds to administer the law which
includes oversight of compliance which
we believe is an important function of
well done
two minutes and 30 seconds you asked for
three so
you're right on any questions for Ms
Hatfield
see none I thank you thank you and I
called the final person to speak on this
bill Sam Evans Brown from clean energy
foreign
ERS yesterday welcome back thank you uh
I'll be I'll be brief many of the points
that I was going to make have been made
already particularly I think when it
comes to the cost of renewable portfolio
standard compliance uh I think that
would be an unintended consequence of
this bill
uh and but I I'd also just like to uh
say again that there are precious few
policies in the state of New Hampshire
that are encouraging fuel diversity at
this point and the renewable portfolio
standard and the renewable energy fund
is uh I would I would argue the the most
powerful uh policy that we have in place
that is in fact encouraging fuel
diversity and uh the the market
structures that we have in New England
at this point have done an excellent job
at ensuring
uh Merit order dispatch of existing
power plants which is to say it's done
an excellent job of ensuring that the
power plants that we have already are uh
the cheapest ones are running first they
have not necessarily done an excellent
job of encouraging a diverse portfolio
of generation assets that can act as a
hedge against volatile fuel prices and
so while uh the the prospect of rate
relief I'm sure is in is an uh
attractive one it's one that comes with
Peril down the road if there is not
investment in different sources of fuel
and if we over invest on a single source
of fuel so I would urge the the
committee to find this bill in expedient
to legislate
um as just a a small note if if we are
looking at thinking of ways for the
renewable energy fund to perhaps be
better leveraged uh there there's there
are plenty of opportunities I would
argue to investigate the ways in which
the rebates and grants are being
dispersed and trying to Target those
rebates and grants at projects that
truly would not happen if it were not
for those grants such as investments in
in new turbines and in you know Hydro
facilities that have a lot of a lot of
upfront Capital costs um that's a
perfect example of the program working
well and and perhaps a path forward
would be to suggest that this bill look
at the at the the structure of of how
the removable energy fund is spent and
ensure that most of those Investments
are in fact additional as opposed to
going to projects that may may be able
to advance on their own merits
great thank you questions for
Mr Mr Sam Evans Brown seeing none I
guess we're done we thank you
so is there anyone else who hasn't
spoken here this morning who would like
to speak to the committee on this uh on
seeing none
I'll close the public hearing on
this bill House Bill 246 and ask
representative closure to give us the
blue sheet recommendation
uh thank you chair Bulls
HB uh Health spill two four six
the blue sheet it was one four and one
against
online it was five four
I'm sorry five in sport
okay thank you
so if anybody needs uh
to take a quick break we'll start our
okay
all right
I'm going to open a public hearing on
House Bill 161 relative to customer
generators of electricity as group hosts
under net metering
the prime sponsor of this bill is
representative McGee who is absent today
and standing in for representative McGee
we're going to call on representative
is that correct representative
McWilliams
apologies I thought representative
Reynolds would introduce this if we
could just wait one moment if not I will
is that all right if we take a minute
okay if somebody could find
representative Reynolds and uh
ah there we go here comes representative
Reynolds
who will now introduce House Bill 161
relative to customer generators of
electricity as group hosts under net
metering
all yours representative
thank you Mr chairman
um
I'm
honored to be here
in the stead of
our distinguished ranking member
representative McGee
um
I wish that it wasn't the case that she
could be here herself but
um hope I'll do it
Justice to uh
testifying on her bill here
this bill hb161 is a
simple bill
correcting language on group net
metering hosting
regarding who is eligible to participate
in the last session the group host
language was modified to include
Municipal group hosts under the statute
RSA 362 A9
section 14a however language remained
that kept
uh
an exclusion for anyone who already
generates any of their own
energy
that is uh exemption I am told by
stakeholders who will likely be
attending the hearing today was intended
from receiving a double benefit
the most likely members in a group
hosting Arrangement are individuals and
businesses who are interested in
offsetting their utility costs by
investing in
local sustainable energy resources in
some cases those looking to join a group
hosting Arrangement already have
for example solar rooftop panels but
they would like to further offset their
energy needs
and and I believe they should have the
right to take part in group posting
um
for net uh
net sorry I've got something going on
they should have the right to take part
in uh group hosting
as both a customer generator and a
member of another group hosting
arrangement the concern for the issue of
double dipping no longer exists because
utilities have
um
implemented the ability to accurately
track net metering credits on customer
bills so the original concern is gone so
the uh
exemption should also be gone
I've also been given examples of
businesses who are currently offsetting
their utility bills by say 10 percent
with previous rooftop solar
installations but who are prohibited
under this exemption from joining a
local group host to purchase additional
clean energy to offset the other 90
percent of their needs in many cases
businesses advertise their
environmentally friendly practices as
part of their branding to customers so
not allowing those people who are most
likely to participate in group hosting
to pursue group hosting deals has the
effect of holding back the free market
it has placed an unnecessary roadblock
in statute
we want New Hampshire rate payers to
participate in locally generated energy
in order to help them lower their bills
competition brings prices down and
reinforces New Hampshire's economy I'll
close by stating that the point of group
hosting is to give people options
to promote competition and to encourage
local control
it's important that we learn from our
own research such as
or our own research that the
long-standing fear of potential cost
shifting was not supported by the
long-awaited value of distributed Energy
report
that incidental cost shifting of perhaps
one percent which was confirmed in the
vder report pales in comparison to the
over 100 percent
electric rate hike that consumers have
suffered in this market
we've been talking about where
competition's been stifled by this
exemption we can start by removing the
group posting exemption that says you
can only participate if you do not
already have any self-cited generation
helping to lower your bills that's an
artificial constraint and it doesn't
help customers lower their bills so if
we can agree that we want to do
everything we can to help Granite
Staters lower their electric bills
okay thank you for introducing this
legislation
now let's find out if the members of the
committee have any questions about it
representative barashni has a question
thank you chairman
um looking at this RSA later down on
line eight it has um the host shell and
then if you continue on to line nine uh
in the middle there shell certified that
all members of the group
and then continue to line 11 that the
total historic annual load of the group
members together with the host exceeds
the projected annual output of the host
facility
so my question is if you remove this
part that says
that other customers can't be customer
generators how can the host certify that
the the total load is not going to be is
going to be a certain amount
so I don't have that language in front
of me but what I do know about the
entire group hosting a group net
metering and group hosting Arrangements
is that the idea
is that
um
the energy consumption
Off the Grid of the group
must exceed that
of the customer cited generation
and so the annual projected production
of a solar facility is a very
predictable
thing and the energy consumption of the
group members is obtained from you know
their historical consumption their bills
so that's that's the way this group net
metering deal Works uh it was this bill
addresses the fact that it was
previously
uh impossible for someone who was
already hosting some solar say of Their
Own
but that solar may have only met like 10
of their building load
they were prevented from participating
in a in a group net meeting or
Arrangement where they could be
sort of virtually getting renewable
energy from another place
so now the utilities have the ability to
um
you know accurately meter and read it so
we don't need to have that exclusion in
I guess follow follow up yep so
this requires it look further down this
requires the host to certify that the
total load is going to be a certain
amount if the host doesn't have control
over what
um
renewable energy some of the customers
may or may not have
and if they can generate their
electricity then that changes the total
load and I don't know how the the the
um the host can certify that
well I'm I'm another aspect of the group
net metering regime is that group hosts
must file a report annually with the puc
so all the participants are required to
keep track and certify annually that
they're um
that their consumption and the
production are are in compliance you
I have a question
so if I'm a customer generator
and I'm net metering myself
and then I get invited by you
to join your group
and you're the host of that group and
you're net metering
why is that not double dipping on that
metering
or how is that not double dipping on
that metering
well because net metering is is just a
uh mechanism
you know well-established used
all over the country
by which
any any excess generation at certain
times of day
uh that that customer cited generation
May produce goes to the grid
and
the customer who owns that generation is
um
you know excess generation
happens during only certain certain
times certain days it doesn't happen on
cloudy days doesn't happen at night
happens during the you know bright
bright sunny so
all of the group all of the net metering
and the group net metering is just
designed to
give proper compensation to those who
have invested their own money in in
generating electricity and putting it on
the grid at Peak at their peak time of
production where it goes over the over
the grid to their neighbor and the
utility sells it
next door so
again the group net metering rules where
which I described earlier
are designed to
not allow
the excess generation you know to sort
of to get out of hand to be more than
the
[Music]
um
the all the members in the group use
the best I can
adding language to this legislation that
would specify that a customer generator
could be a member of the group as long
as that customer generator did not net
meter him or herself would that be
something that could be clarifying for
this legislation I think that would be
counter to the intent of the legislation
um
the reason
for the reason we don't it isn't fair uh
and it's unnecessary it's an it's an
infringement to exclude
a customer who is simply who is net
metering
um
from also being a member of a group is
because
um
the
customer-sighted generation you know
rarely
rarely meets the the needs of that the
total energy needs of that customer all
the time it's the
uh rare is the building who's who's
energy needs can be met by a solar array
on the roof
so you put solar all over the roof that
you can if you're an industrial customer
say down in Hudson in the in the energy
most of the time there's no net metering
going on because the
um
consumption in that building is so high
but sometimes uh
you know again a couple of months of the
year a couple of days of the month there
may be some exporting going on
and that's the only time when you know
net metering is in play that that that
customer generator is getting paid by
for the energy they export
the utility is immediately reselling
that energy to the to their next door
neighbor
um but you know other members
um
so they might want to join a group net
metering arrangement
to have more of their energy come from
solar and they're you know they're still
paying for that energy they're not it's
okay additional questions for
representative Reynolds
seeing none I thank you for introducing
thank you Bill 161
next I'll call upon
Griffin robarge from the Department of
energy to give us the Department's
perspective on this legislation proposed
legislation
foreign
thank you chairman Vos members of the
committee for the record again Griffin
Roberge State energy program manager at
the New Hampshire Department of energy
is opposed to House Bill 161 as
introduced
um for background uh this state statute
was modified and I should say State
Statute itself was modified in 2013 to
establish uh group net metering the
statute permits net metered renewable
energy facilities known as group hosts
to share the proceeds of surplus
electricity generation with other
electric utility account holders known
as group members group members must not
be customer generators themselves under
the current statute and do not need uh
I'm sorry uh do not need to be customer
generated as was originally outlined
when the statute was created and do not
need to make any changes to their
existing electric service in these
arrangements as has been discussed the
total load of the group host plus all
the group members must be greater or
equal to the annual generation output
from the group host generation
the theory behind this statute when it
was created was to direct the benefits
of net metering to customers or group
members who could not take advantage of
net metering themselves because they did
not have the means to fund or construct
a net metering facility either a
customer generator acting as a group
host either you're on one side or the
other of a certain line either you are a
group host and you're a customer
generator and you're sharing those
benefits with group members or you are a
group or you're a member of that group
you're not a customer generator yourself
you couldn't be on both sides of the
line simultaneously last year Senate
Bill 262 which was signed into law
originally sought to remove the
requirement as House Bill 161 is doing
here
remove the requirement that group
members shall not be customer generators
themselves public testimony as Senate
Bill 262 is working its way through the
legislative process indicated that the
statute was limiting to to uh to
Municipal group host net metering
Arrangements group host Arrangements
couldn't be formed in a Municipality of
say a fire station or a town hall had a
net meter facility on it and you had a
larger you know group host down the road
um doe at that time proposed language
which you see online five to six which
would narrowly allow an exception for
political subdivisions such as cities
towns counties chartered public schools
and certain types of customer generators
in another area of statute
that language was amended before this
committee and was ultimately what was
signed into law giving municipalities a
great flexibility
um for these group host net meeting
arrangements and as I mentioned that
language is found on lines five to six
that's the exception
um as I mentioned House Bill 161 seeks
to accomplish what Senate Bill 262 last
year originally intended the bill would
broadly expand the number and types of
customers who can take part in group net
metering Arrangements including group
members who are already customer
generators themselves in our opinion
this policy changed significantly Alters
the intent of the group net metering
statute from one that seeks to direct
net metering benefits to those who
cannot be customer generators themselves
to those who may already have the means
of controlling their energy costs as
customer generators
we do see we do view this as a
department as a sizable change as I
mentioned to the group metering statute
and as a note the puc currently has an
ongoing docket looking into revisions to
the net energy metering tariffs in
de-22-060 I think the department would
respectfully suggest laying the puc
arrive at those decisions through that
adjudication uh with an active
stakeholder engagement process through
an active adjudication before making
substantial changes as is being proposed
in house bill 161.
should the committee feel differently
and wish to move forward with the
proposed language unamended doe would
suggest removing the language on lines
five to six if the intent is to allow
customer generators to be group members
and group host Arrangements removing the
sentence on or sorry retaining the
sentence on lines five to six would make
a little sense it's just kind of hanging
there
um
and with that happy to take uh any
thank you questions from the committee
representative Harrington has a question
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
um I'm just trying to figure the flow of
all this if this bill passed and maybe
you can help me out with it a little bit
it would appear that if you're a
customer generator and you're also a net
in your your net need ring and then you
become part of a group that also has a
generator because obviously that's why
you would join so then your options
could be you could net meter onto the
grid you could obviously consume your
own electricity you could Supply
electricity to the group host uh
entity or you could collect electricity
from the group host and how would we
keep track of all these different
options if they indeed are all options
so thank you for the question um when it
comes to group host net medium
Arrangements there are
um applications that need to take place
so people submit obviously to the New
Hampshire Department of energy in order
to enter into these type of arrangements
and then detail how benefits are
allocated out
um if the language were to go forward
you know utilities also you know
ascertain how much generation is being
consumed within the group I imagine if
you have customer generators in that
that utilities would likely measure the
net from that customer generator who's a
group member so they might be
net metering themselves and consuming
some of that power
the difference that they maybe aren't
meeting with their own facility would
likely be used to calculate on the group
net metering Arrangement
um
back up I guess holistically is that you
know I think the department feels is
that
the intent of the statute as was
originally prescribed years ago was to
drive the benefits of net metering to
those who cannot take advantage of net
metering themselves with this bill is to
go forward you are allowing those who
are already customer generators to then
also get the benefit of group host net
metering as well we just feel like that
that's a sizable change from what's been
intended
follow up follow up and but you would
agree that this creates a much larger
complication than just trying to keep
track of all the flow of the power
because of all these various options
that now would be I think folks in our
consumer division would would agree with
that sentiment thank you
representative Summers has a question
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question and you may or may
not know the answer to this but there
was a case in California in 2021
pertaining to a Ponzi scheme where the
host was a solar provider and then group
members were solar members and each
group member was to bring on more so or
solar members and it was found to be I
think the owner of found find 30 years
in prison would this pause could this
possibly happen in this case if this
bill was to where hosts and the
generators could both and uh generators
could also become
um
combining the group at the same time
producing itself thank you for the
question I would be reluctant to assume
that something like that could take
place in New Hampshire I'm not overly
familiar with the circumstances that you
refer to in California obviously each
state has different
um net metering laws and that type of
thing I'm not sure if there was
something that was applicable more to
California than maybe what would be done
here in New Hampshire so
um respectfully I couldn't comment too
much on that but thank you
representative munz has a question
thank you Mr chair and thanks for being
here again
um
apologize if I missed something in your
description
um
there is an exception for political
subdivisions so towns and can join can
can
be a customer generator and join a group
host
um presumably that was because there was
a benefit to them in terms of lower
rates
and if that is in fact the case then why
shouldn't you know other consumers have
the same benefit of a rate reduction
thank you for the question so I think I
just back up a little bit to when the
group I'm sorry the municipal host
um statute was created this will the
statute
um allows Municipal hosts to operate
above one megawatt but less than five to
group net meter with political
subdivision so that cities towns what
have you
um I think the theory behind that was
that
um obviously the legislature decided
that that's something worthwhile to
direct benefit to municipalities but
that never existed before so you might
have had municipalities who might not
necessarily have the load to satisfy a
group host net metering Arrangements
such as under the municipal host statute
going back to the example you might have
a fire station or a town hall that
already had
um
a solar facility on it
um they couldn't include that in a group
host net metering Arrangement so what
was done last year was it created that
narrow carve out to give a little bit of
a narrower flexibility to municipalities
given the expansion of of uh the net
meter and crap for municipal host
statute
um I think broadly I guess expanding
that and just saying you can be a
customer generator or whatever you can
now take part in these group hosts would
be a sizable change from what was done
under the municipal host statute and
follow up
um
granted it would be a significant change
but would it have a positive impact on
rates
if you're asking me for like a specific
data or anything like that I couldn't
give that right now but I think I would
defer just because the pews as I
mentioned the puc is currently
adjudicating this issue and determining
whether any changes to the net metering
tariffs should take place I'm sure for
folks that it would you know I'm sure
for folks there would be a benefit if
you're a customer generator yourself and
want to take part in a group host net
medium Arrangement but again we've
always viewed the intent of the statute
with directing the benefits of group
host and net metering to those who
cannot take advantage of be a customer
generator themselves
representative partial no McWilliams has
a question thank you chair Bose um and
thank you Mr Roberts for your testimony
today
a question about
um the value of distributed Energy
report yes where we determine there's
less than one percent cost shifting in
large net metering or really any net
metering
um so I want to understand I I know we
were dipping our toes in the water when
we first started in 2013 with the
legislative intent either to be a group
host or a member you couldn't be on both
sides of the line and now it looks like
we're starting to open things up to
municipalities to your point so I guess
my question is how many customer
generators does this proposed Bill
exempt so thank you for the question
um I'd have to at least maybe shop that
around with our consumer services
division just because they register
these group hosts and that type of thing
I I not aware that the department
currently registers folks for being an
independent customer generator it's more
for I believe cut group host net
metering arrangements as is defined in
the statute regarding the vder study you
know obviously that study was not was
brought about per puc order in an
earlier net metering docket the study
was crafted in an effort to kind of pave
the way for the puc's future
adjudication looking into net metering
statutes into whether cost shifting is
occurring obviously the vder study found
very very very minimal effects of cost
shifting but broadly the questions of to
whether or not cost shifting is
occurring is an open question that's
currently pending before the puc the
vder study we would submit is a part of
that is a part of maybe answering that
question so sizable changes such as this
I think we would suggest
should maybe be reserved for when the
puc finally reaches its its uh reaches
a conclusion date of this puc follow-up
to the vder study I thought we were
pretty much clear that it's new so what
is the date of this next study sure
thank you very much for the question so
I know the P the puc issued an order
early last year opening up
um uh potential revisions to the net
metering statute I can certainly share
that notice with folks here on the
committee in the first paragraph of that
and I'm doing this for memory it's cited
Senate Bill 261 from last year and House
Bill 1599 as reasons to potentially open
up the docket again to look at net
metering statute so again letting the
puc to fully adjudicate these issues
before making sizable changes might be
something for the legislature to
consider
okay seeing no further questions from
the committee we want to thank you Mr
Roberts thank you
presenting the Department's perspective
on this legislation next I'll call
the final person who has signed up to
speak on this bill and that's
Jim Monahan who is representing revision
energy
good morning uh good morning
um
uh Mr chairman I'm Jim Monahan with the
DuPont group I'm here today on behalf of
revision energy I'm glad I got to speak
class because I think there was some
clarity that came through the questions
where I think we can resolve some of the
open issues before the committee
um let me just say the uh uh the uh
practical issues that we're trying to
resolve with this bill are situations
where a group is forming or a group has
formed for net metering and a customer
who already has
self-generating typically a solar panel
wants to join the group
and so
um uh there's nothing a state law that
says that customer can't join the group
so it wouldn't necessarily expand it but
what it does as a practical matter the
situation says but that existing solar
rate you have on your roof you have to
unplug it and take it take it away you
can't make it part of the group so I
think Representatives I actually had a
client yesterday who signed off an email
saying um Clarity is kindness and I
think you offered some kindness and your
observations the intention here is to
avoid double dipping not to allow for it
so I think your suggestion that language
be put in the bill to be clear that
we're not allowing the existing
self-generator to double dip is is will
add Clarity to the conversation here so
I appreciate that
um you know the Practical
um situation we're offering here is not
to expand group net metering beyond the
limitations that they're now uh it
wouldn't change the credits suit
wouldn't affect many of the issues or
any of the issues perhaps that the of
the puc is considering in the in the
Vita study is just trying to deal with a
very practical situation where somebody
decided to self-generate several years
ago and now there's the opportunity for
them to join a group they should be able
to do so they shouldn't be allowed to
double dip and we want to get rid of
that that situation so we can come up
with some hopefully work with you in the
committee to come up with language of
that I can talk to the Department of
energy to see if it resolves some of
their concerns
um and um
uh there's one last thing that and I'll
talk to Griff about this but and I just
caught it now but on line eight uh of
the bill uh it makes reference to
um the the host shall provide a list of
members to the commission but the
balance of the bill talks about
providing information to the department
I think this is just one of the and I
can double check this with an apartment
I just think it's one more of those
situations when you created a department
of energy uh you transferred
responsibility this is just we're
catching them as we come along I think
that's probably something that uh we
want to correct here as well so as long
as we're if we if we are working on an
amendment or do that uh with regard to
um Mr Griffin's observations that uh if
this uh bill is enacted uh I you know I
think there's right it may again be kind
with Clarity and remove the uh uh or you
may not need the political subdivision
carve out because you'd be allowing this
for for uh anyone that came to it
finally from a another practical concern
and that is that if a existing generator
self-generator is going to join a group
and they surrender their uh their the
credit responsibility and join the hope
it may mean that the group group then
can build a smaller
self-generating facility because they'd
be able to move the power uh from the
existing facility uh uh into the into
the larger group so there's that cost
savings for the group and and for the
the members that are there so I don't
see this necessarily as a huge in a
certainly Department of energy that can
change my mind in this uh this is some
sort of
um substantial uh change in things
particularly if we're not allowing the
the
double dipping um and honestly the uh as
I said before we're not asking to change
the current restrictions on the size and
composition of a group
um the um
I'll leave it at that and answer any
representative Corman has a question
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question so do I understand
correctly that as long as there would be
some language added to this bill as an
amendment to prohibit double dipping
that you would be in favor of it
absolutely yes thank you and I apologize
for not having you know throughout the
course of the summer the folks at
revision works with many of the
utilities to work out the mechanics of
this we just the presumption was we were
attempting to eliminate the double
dipping we think we did but adding it in
the bill doesn't create any harm to what
we're trying to achieve here and in fact
creates the clarity we think would be
helpful
representative munz has a question
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
clearing up some of this stuff just to
follow up on representative Corman so as
I understood what you said what you want
to do is
not is allow someone that has a solar
panel for example who wants to join the
group allow them to not have to unplug
the panel like they have to do now
correct but then all but also not get
any kind of financial benefit
by virtue of tapping into net metering
twice right they'd have to surrender and
no longer take the credit they get from
the utility instead they would get the
the benefit as being a part of the the
group and the host would manage that
um compensation for them okay thank you
so
my question would be about the language
that Mr robarge referred to in lines six
or pardon me five and six the exception
that was added last year
as an amendment the house bill 2 or
essentially that ex exemption was
designed to deal with political
subdivisions correct so
let's take my town of Epping as an
example
let's say uh we put a we have a a solar
installation on our our Municipal safety
complex
and revision energy comes in and they
want to put up a solar array and add our
library and our town hall and
um our historical society and other
municipal buildings
to a group
for which they become the host
[Music]
this exemption would allow our safety
complex which also has solar panels on
is the motivation for revision energy
to try to gobble up all of the potential
load that a town has
uh so as to build the biggest possible
facility that it can
and therefore net meter as much power as
it possibly can
under the under the current law is that
yes
well um
I'd have to get I'd have to talk to them
but I think the the general and I you
know we can have folks that come in and
size these things for customers I think
the general sense is that you're trying
to build the solar facility to match the
load and so there's you know they're
just trick to getting that right
um so
um I'm not sure the
gobble up is the industry term that
they're necessarily use but I think
they're trying to match it but I think
they you know if you're going to be in
the business of uh working for the town
of Epping you want to maximize the value
so I think that they would try to to do
that and the example of your safety
complex they would want to be able to
use that facility to help you know feed
the other
Municipal facilities so that's
the the what was allowed for under the
provisions of Senate Bill 262 last year
so you didn't have that ironic situation
where your safety building in Epping
which already has solar wouldn't be part
of the group you'd want it to be it
would make sense for that
to occur and this simply makes the same
uh adjustment for uh residential
businesses Farms other people that want
are willing to surrender their current
credit to become part of a group
okay thank you further questions
representative munz I'm thank you Mr
chairman I'm sorry I just just thought
of something yeah I mean and you know
excuse my ignorance but
um
if if you know let's say that let's use
the town of Epping where they're they're
getting their own net metering credit
and then they join a group and you know
they could get another credit
is there anything that prevents somebody
that's a customer generator a customer a
customer generator
that's already getting a rate from then
sharing that rate with everybody else in
addition to the rate the net metering
rate they get as part of the group
I guess what I'm coming back to is is
there a is is there a potential benefit
to all of the members of the group by
having double dipping
I my instinct says no you double
dippings usually looked as a as
something you wouldn't necessarily yeah
so you know I and
you know I presume the example that
representative votes talked about is
that the safety building in Epping
doesn't double dip you know they've come
to some sort of a mechanism to ensure
that that wouldn't happen if that but I
think adding that Clarity in the in the
statute makes sense
representative Harrington has a question
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question I'm just trying to
get my handle on this double dipping so
let me just kind of walk through a
little bit and see if I've got it and
correct me if I'm wrong
um right now you have someone who is a
net metering generator and they're
generating out uh you know through the
net metering statute and uh they put
sometimes they're putting a power on the
grid sometimes they're consuming it and
then there's a group organization that
is made up of a generator and then other
customers who consume electricity and
they sometimes produce enough
electricity for the whole group
sometimes they're taking it Off the Grid
sometimes they may even be exporting it
onto the grid now when you combine the
two of them together what the double
dipping part that you want to eliminate
is the ability for both generators to
export independently onto the Grid or
the net meter so they would only go the
electricity from the the new generator
joining the group could only go for
their own use or for use for the other
people in the group but they couldn't
net meter it as an individual while they
were part of the group is that what
um I think so but so the situation
talked about would be you know both the
incumbent the Legacy facility and the
new facility would both
uh export into the you know in into the
grid but the Legacy customer
uh would would not get
the existing credit Arrangement he or
she has with the utility they would
surrender surrender that and instead be
compensated by
the host and the host is managing both
the new generating facility and the
Legacy facility when it comes to export
okay and just a quick follow-up I just
yes
um
as I mentioned earlier the department of
energy person I just wonder how
complicated this is going to be to
manage from a from a rate point of view
to keep track of it I don't know if the
utilities are putting any thought to
that yet but it'd be interesting to
figure out if it's if this is something
that it can it it first of all can it be
done and how complicated is it going to
be to do it so yeah uh usually when I
get questions like that I say well we
gave these people an absolute Monopoly
they can figure it out but I won't say
that today
um so I you know but there is I think
there is a an emerging responsibility in
the part of the utility is to come up
with mechanisms to handle this type of
thing particularly as the legislature
and policy makers you know will it be at
the expansion of Municipal net meeting
last year I think it's you know uh that
there may be some administrative
challenges but I think they're up to the
task all right thank you and I have
heard you say not say that many times in
I'm being kind this morning
representative Harrington
so again we're not trying to change the
world here we're trying to address a
practical situation we're a you know uh
uh a
a host situation should be welcoming of
somebody who's already kind of made the
investment we just want to handle the
mechanics to make sure that they they
can join we're not and and we're not
trying to create any extra
um uh benefit to either the host or the
generator that's participating
okay thank you okay so you know further
questions I would like to ask Mr Roberts
if you could come back up uh because
because I have a question about how this
whole group net metering
Arrangement Works in practice and I'm
hopeful that you can maybe provide an
thank you chairman Vos I will try if I
can't I will follow that up with the
committee okay thank you so here's my
question it was my understanding
that the way group net metering works
is that the host the customer generator
who's the host
when he supplies his power to the group
members
that's treated as net metered power and
he receives credit
against the power that he sends out to
the group members at the at the net
metering rate
is that the way net group net metering
works I believe that to be the case yes
so you follow under uh depending on the
size of the group host obviously you'd
fall under the applicable net metering
tariff so 1.0 2.0 whether or not you're
one to 100 kilowatt one 100 kilowatts to
one megawatt
um obviously any type of application to
have a any type of desire to enter a
group PostNet mirror Arrangement as Mr
Monahan did point out
um does not go to the puc anymore it
goes to the department so I would agree
um that probably a good housekeeping
change on line eight would make sense
from commission to department
but all of those are reviewed by the
department they were they are uh all of
the applications are reviewed by the
department to ensure that they are in
conformance with State Statute and
administrative rule
um yes I'll stop there I'm rambling
so just to sum up the benefit to the
members of the group is that the host is
receiving compensation that allows him
to charge group members less money for
it can but there's also and I can unpack
this a little bit more with follow-up to
the committee there is also the option
for on bill crediting so that members
group members see a direct benefit on
their electric bill from these group
hostnet meeting Arrangements
um what you're describing group host
gets a benefit and then disperses it I
think that's an option but it's not the
only option I guess I could say great
thank you for that clarification I
appreciate it
all right representative Harrington has
a question for you thank you Mr chairman
let me take my question I'm still trying
to follow the logic on this so let's
let's get to the world where we have
these we have an existing uh group that
has net metering in it and they they
just like I said before they would
either their options are they produce
electricity from their solar facility
some days they consume it all some days
they have uh Surplus and they put it
back on the grid uh some days they have
to import from the grid now we bring in
this new second generator comes in who
was previously net metering let's say
they're all under a megawatt so they're
on the default service rate is to make
things simplify so that person was doing
basically the same thing as an
individual and they were selling it
exporting it to the grid and getting
default service rate sometimes they
import sometimes they cover their own
use with their own generation now when
they join that of that other group what
how is the electricity they produce
treated is it when they
produce it and it goes into other group
members is that just internal to the
group or do they get they get default
service rate for that how does that work
I'm not uh thank you for the question if
it's all right I would like to follow up
with you just because Amanda Noonan on
our and our consumer services division
can probably vet that a little bit more
thoroughly than I can sitting here right
here and now her team goes through that
quite quite often and I think they're a
little bit more familiar with the
changes with the narrow exception that
was proposed in Senate Bill 262 I
realized the urgency and getting more
information on this so let me unpack
that with staff and I'll follow up all
right thank you because it is pretty
confusing that's Bob thank you
who would be the correct person within
the doe to give us a tutorial on group
net metering it would likely be uh
Deandra
um I'm not even going to try pronouncing
her last name and I'm hoping she's not
watching because I'm going to butcher it
um but Amanda Noonan as well
um there is a slightly we do have a page
on our website to kind of give a a high
level overview of as to how group net
mirroring Arrangements work
um but Deanna Deandra has been out sick
and Amanda Noonan has been out of the
office as well so I want to talk to them
a little bit more before presenting
information make sure it's accurate
okay I may ask the department to give us
a tutorial on group net metering at some
point in the future it'll probably be a
couple of months down the road but
just alert them if you will to the fact
that we will be looking for that just to
make sure we fully understand it yep
okay
thank you for coming up and answering
our questions is there anyone else in
the audience who would like to speak on
seeing none I'm going to close this
public hearing on House Bill 161 and ask
representative closure to give us the
blue sheet
statistics
thank you chairman Bulls House Bill 161
the blue sheet was seven in favor
none opposed online it was 66 in favor
none opposed
okay thank you very much
and that concludes our morning activity
lunch break starts right now
and we will return here at 1 30 to hear
the next bill on our list which is house
bill 165. so we'll see you then have a
foreign
okay ladies and gentlemen Gentlemen
let's resume our activity for today the
final day of January for 2023. at the
beginning of our session this morning I
mentioned that representative Thomas and
I wanted to do some experimentation
with our scheduling and wanted to get
the input of the members of the
committee on
our
ideas our plans
so the first plan was to schedule public
hearings for one half hour each instead
of an hour
and if any public hearing exceeded that
30-minute span
we would open the next public hearing
but then return to the previous public
hearing and leave the the subsequent
public hearing open until we got to it
some other committees do business this
way and it seems to work for them
the Senate often does business this way
in fact the Senate sometimes even
schedules bills at 15-minute intervals
so that's one idea that we're we're
toying with and
um I'd like to get a sense from members
of the committee if they'd be willing to
experiment with that idea for a couple
of sessions a couple of committee uh
sessions and see how it works uh
representative Wendy Thomas yes thank
you I'd just like to to clarify that you
spoke with representative Doug Thomas
I feel that's very important okay
representative Doug Thomas and I came up
with this idea just reversed me as the
taller one
the taller Thomas
helped us come up with that idea the
other idea that we want to bounce off
people
I've been scheduling exec sessions at
four o'clock in the afternoon
and
that runs the risk that we might be here
until five or six or
potentially even seven o'clock in the
evening
which makes for a long day
so representative Doug Thomas and I have
discussed the potential of moving exec
Shadow sessions to either the first
thing in the morning at nine o'clock or
moving them to one o'clock in the
afternoon
and then potentially having public
hearings after the exec sessions does
anybody have any strong feelings about
that representative Kaplan yeah I would
have a strong objection to doing it at
nine in the morning just because of my
own personal situation I you know I I
work in the mornings so that would make
it very difficult for me
how about one o'clock that would be
acceptable
representative barajny I have the same
situation one o'clock would work better
thank you
representative Harrington anything's
better than four
thank you
representative Wendy Thompson Thomas
um thank you but this just to make clear
this would not add another hearing day
right this would just adjust times yes
the the idea is we'd still meet on
Mondays and Tuesdays we wouldn't add a
third day except in the case of this
week where we got snowed out I would
prefer one o'clock
no other feelings from the committee
okay so when you see the schedule for
next week oh representative partial
thank you chair
um I'd just like to weigh in on the idea
of how things work in the Senate
um or in my particular case how things
don't work I think 15 minutes is really
too brief I I would be happy to
experiment with a half hour but I would
urge you to avoid the logger gems that
we have in the Senate when people are
waiting to testify there in this thing
about people waiting in the hall
yes I would never go to 15 minutes I
just mentioned that they did it that way
in the Senate just to be illustrative of
other ways of doing things
so when you see your schedule next week
we will probably experiment with doing
and we'll just do it for one week and
see how it goes and then we'll decide we
want to keep doing it this way or do we
want to go back to an hour what seems to
work
and then we'll also schedule our public
hearings not at four o'clock
probably not at nine o'clock so it's
probably one o'clock but we'll make that
determination you'll you'll see it in
the calendar next week representative
McWilliams
thank you so much chairman Bose I think
that half an hour makes a lot of sense
but we might want to just allow a little
bit of catch-up time so I would propose
normally we would do 9 to 12 three bills
if we did 9 to 11 30 five bills and it
allows that half hour for running to
noon for the lunch break that might give
us a buffer
okay good suggestion representative Doug
Thomas thank you Mr yeah that's exactly
what I proposed to the chair so thank
you for that
um
this will perhaps uh perhaps shouldn't
be doesn't have to be said but maybe
does
with this type of schedule it will
incentivize people to stick to the
selling points of their comments and
their testimony uh perhaps we can get
better you know Point said during that
brief time period so other people can
grief as well within the uh same time
period
good point
any further comments on this proposal or
these proposals
representative notter
thank you Mr chairman I think it's one
of those things where if you wash the
car it's going to rain so if you
schedule 15 minutes we're going to have
a room full of people if you schedule an
hour we will have a 15-minute hearing
this is the way it goes
there is a certain amount of that that's
life right it's called life so okay well
thank you for giving us your sense of of
how things might go we'll do some
experimenting next week and then
will regroup and discuss how it went and
then chart a path forward from there
so with that we can now move on to the
business of the afternoon which is to
open a public hearing on House Bill
165. relative to Department of energy
procedures in lieu of meeting renewable
portfolio standards for biomass and I'll
call on the prime sponsor of House Bill
165 representative Michael Harrington to
this should be relatively easy
um because of a confusion in my spot
when I was writing these actually I was
on vacation trying to get lsrs caught up
anyways uh I'd like to itl the bill the
um class one class three
um renewable portfolio requirement is
now administratively been lowered to one
percent because it just simply isn't
enough uh pre-2006 wood burning plants
to make up the higher number so uh this
bill has become basically unnecessary so
I just I can't withdraw it so I'm hoping
everyone will agree with me just vote
IDL and I'll take any questions
anybody any questions for representative
Harrington
seeing none I guess you're off the hook
all right
I have a pink card here from Jason stock
of the Timberland Owners Association now
Mr stock
wanted to testify on both
this bill and the next bill which is
house bill 166.
and uh
I'm perfectly willing to allow that so
Mr stock if you want to come and give us
your your take on these two bills I
guess your take on 165 will be pretty
brief
but um
you can let us know your feelings about
166 and be economical with your time or
if you would prefer you could just wait
until 166.
um
okay
so representative Thomas Doug Thomas
just asked me the question can this
testimony be accepted if if the bill
hasn't been introduced
so that's a relevant question so maybe
we should ask you to wait until we
another reason for a half hour public
hearing
representative McWilliams my
rank exact immediately would it make
sense to use this time to exec the bill
all right so we're going to um we're
going to ask you Mr stock to hang on for
a little while uh we'll ask you to come
back
um for 166. I don't want to risk your
testimony not being valid for 166 so
so uh
what we will do then is uh let's see
nope that was for 166.
so nobody else has signed up to speak on
House Bill 165
is there anybody in the audience who
seeing no one I'm going to close the
public hearing on House Bill 165.
and now I will open an executive session
on House Bill 165
and recognize representative Harrington
for a motion uh I moved to uh make the
bill itl inappropriate to legislate
a recognize representative McWilliams
I second that it's been moved and
seconded that we itl House Bill
seeing none I'll ask the clerk to call
the roll on the question of itl for
Douglas Thomas
yes
Janine nodder yes
Michael Harrington
yes
Troy is not here
lewicki is not here Lex barajny yes
JD Bernardi yes Tom blochet yes
McGee is not here Rebecca Williams Mike
creation is not here Lewis partial
yes
Tony Kaplan yes
see not here
not here
uh Henry Noel
yes
Wendy Thomas yes
Thomas Corman yes
Ned Reynolds yes
one two three four five six seven oh
chairman Vose yes
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten eleven twelve thirteen fourteen
fifteen fifteen years
so the motion to itl house built 165
passes
without objection I'll make sure that it
goes on the consent calendar and
representative Harrington if you could
write a brief committee report
and have that to me by the end of the
and with that we'll close the executive
session on House Bill 165.
and unfortunately we now have
45 minutes
that we have to wait until we can start
so
this committee will be in recess until 2
30.
oh
foreign okay good afternoon everybody
time to open a public hearing on House
Bill 166 relative to the elimination of
useful thermal energy from renewable
energy classes
any of you in the audience who were here
back at 1 30 when we resumed our
afternoon activity here we'll recall a
discussion we had about scheduling our
public hearings for one half hour
instead of an hour
so I'd like you all to pretend that this
is a half hour public hearing
and base your
comments on that time frame let's see
how it goes Let's do an experiment
so with that I'd like to uh introduce
the prime sponsor of this bill
representative Michael Harrington to
introduce the legislation the proposed
legislation
thank you Mr chairman good afternoon
um there's a few parts to this bill but
I want to kind of explain what the
purpose of it and why I've brought it
forward and one of the things we always
hear about is transparency in government
everybody gives uh platitudes to a
transparency we want to know people know
what's going on we shouldn't be hiding
things in the layers of bureaucratic
Bowl uh people should be straight out
know what's going on but in this case
if you ask the average person in New
Hampshire if their electric bill was
higher because they were subsidizing
someone burning wood chips in a furnace
someplace they'd either laugh at you or
say I have no idea what you're talking
about but that is indeed what happens
we've been using the electric bills to
hide subsidies to selected companies who
are very good at lobbying uh down here
in Concord and get bills passed to get
them subsidies at the expense of the
electric rate payers
the rate payers are under a lot of
pressure we've been hearing now all the
last couple of weeks how rates are high
we need to do something there's only so
much we can do here on the state level
because so much is controlled on the
regional and federal level
but there are a few things and every
time someone brings one up someone says
well it's only going to be ten dollars
or it's only going to be 15 but you know
eventually those add up and they do show
the rate pays that at least we're trying
so
first reason for this bill is
transparency let's get the hidden tax on
electricity out get rid of it if people
feel that burning wood chips is such a
great idea then let them put a tax on
oil or gas or something where it comes
out and says tax to subsidize burning
wood chips and everyone will know what
they're paying for anyways that's
transparency in government
second with the amount of we've been
told about and I think I mentioned this
earlier if we've heard about it on the
radio we've heard people testifying here
about it there are billions that would
be billions of dollars of federal tax
dollars your tax dollars they're going
to be spent on virtually anything that
resembles Energy Efficiency or renewable
any energy projects anything you can
possibly think of that would fit into
that category is going to be eligible
for billions of dollars we don't need to
be spending New Hampshire rate pays
dollars on the same thing there's
probably more money going to be out
there in companies could actually handle
but again there's so many billions of
dollars on the federal level this is our
opportunity to save our state rate
payers something
it's
also the fact is you're going to hear
always they'll come out and say this and
this happens on every one of these
programs it's not unique to this
particular bill or even this particular
industry well if we collect all this
money and we put it in a big bucket and
give it to some bureaucrats then they're
going to spend it and they're going to
say it's going to create millions of
jobs or thousands of jobs and create to
stimulate the economy but they never
talk about how many jobs would have been
created and how much the economy would
have been stimulated if we allowed the
people to keep their own money and spend
it as they thought was the best way to
do it my contention is that they're
going to be much more efficient than
spending the money than the government's
going to be and it'll create more jobs
and stimulate the economy more and the
government won't be in the position to
pick winners and losers and I say this
with some experience because as a former
puc commissioner I used to sign grants
for thousands and thousands of dollars
to selected companies that would get
money from the rate pays because that
was part of my job I had no I couldn't
all I could do is the best of my ability
I certainly could not do it
and I gotta tell you I had no skin in
the game on that there was no it was not
like I was spending my own money and
that's the same for everybody else
everyone's going to spend their own
money with more care and consideration
what's best for them and their family
than the some government bureaucrat's
going to spend it for somebody else most
people can't afford the time to come
down here and hire lobbyists and pay
them thousands of dollars to lobby for
more subsidies from the rate payers some
businesses can and I'm sure after I
stopped speaking you'll hear from them
so people are more efficient at spending
their own money
and there's also just a simple fact of
force versus Freedom there's nothing
that stops people from subsidizing or
buying these uh Energy Efficiency or
wood products you can buy as much as
they want but what we're saying
basically is no no no the government
knows better we are smarter than the
average person the average person won't
do the right thing if they're allowed
the freedom to make that decision for
themselves so we're going to force them
to subsidize in this case useful thermal
energy which has really nothing to do
with electric rates other than like I
said there was very good lobbyists were
able to come down and get that put in
there as a bill because we have a lot of
wood chip manufacturers uh in in the
state so
as far as a technical part of the bill
because of what we did last earlier
today on 165 Section 3 would be removed
completely it's no longer necessary so
that part that won't change the section
on page the other part that's a major
change is on page one uh where it talks
about the various classes and again it
puts a cap on these classes otherwise
they're going to grow and grow and grow
and it's again it comes down to the
simple fact if anybody in the state I
don't know most people may or may not be
aware there's a law in the state of New
Hampshire that says every utility must
offer up to 100 Renewable Power to any
one of the people that takes default
service well you don't hear too much
about that because back a few years ago
the utilities came to the puc and they
petitioned it and said you know we're
getting somewhere around point zero
percent of the people voluntarily
signing up to pay more for Renewable
Power so the commission had the
authority under the law to suspend that
law but that law could be brought back
and the utilities could do it so the way
with it's the way with all is there if
people want to pay extra for solar or
wind or wood chips or useful thermal
energy or not useful thermology but the
other ones they can certainly do that
would apply to any of these classes in
the RPS standard they simply have to say
they want it and they can get it but you
know what they're not saying that so
again the government has stepped in and
said we know better than you do the
average person is too stupid to be left
with a decision on how to buy
electricity so the government must
substitute their judgment for them and
I'm saying I don't think that's
necessary I think the people of New
Hampshire are smart enough to make these
decisions for themselves it wouldn't
eliminate the RPS but it would put the
brakes on it again all this idea of
building new renewable energy is more
than going to be covered by billions of
dollars in federal grants and federal
programs that are going to be coming out
so we don't need to punish the people of
no New Hampshire any further for not
quote buying the right type of energy
voluntarily I think given to their own
choice they'll do quite well and I'm
willing to take any questions
okay thank you representative Harrington
for introducing this legis proposed
legislation representative Summers asked
a question thank you Mr chairman just a
very quick question from what we the
testimony we heard last week I believe
and would you believe not excuse me and
rephrase that is it true that
Massachusetts no longer considers
burning wood as a renewable energy
resource it's I I it's very restrictive
on there I I think it's I don't know the
exact numbers but it has to do with the
thermal efficiency of the plant and to
get a full wreck in Massachusetts would
be impossible because I think you need a
thermal efficiency of somewhere around
40 or 50 percent which burning green
would you can never even get close to
they run around 18 so they have some but
it's very limited on that thermal
okay additional questions representative
Kaplan
thank you Mr chair and uh thank you
representative for introducing this bill
um I would agree with uh most of your
assessment and what you know the
philosophical approach that you're
taking to uh the RPS I just you know I
wanted to ask you
would you ever consider that Society has
a greater responsibility to make changes
in the way we do anything uh that would
outweigh an individual's right to make
an immediate choice in the marketplace I
mean is there any circumstance that you
would ever think that an individual's
right to make a choice a consumer choice
is outweighed by you know the greater
public good well and certainly I'm I'm
not going to sit here and try to list
them but I'm certainly think someone
could come up with one where I would say
I would agree with it but in this case
it simply isn't necessary because the
mechanism is there the law is already
passed if we all we have to do is
reinstate that which could be done by a
puc decision or a request of the
utilities for that matter and anybody
that wants to get 80 percent uh 90 100
could get it out of the utilities and
even beyond that if you go to
competitive suppliers I know I was
talking to uh uh Peters I always screw
up his last name Psalms some help me out
Michael
a couple of months ago and he was
telling me how with the higher electric
rates he was like because he had gone in
for 100 wind power at eight cents a
kilowatt hour for a three-year contract
so it's very possible to do that and you
people can choose that for themselves we
don't need the government making them
choose for because basically what
they're saying is if you don't choose
right you're going to pay for it anyways
because these companies are going to
have to go get alternate compliance
payments but in this case there simply
isn't a need to do that we have a
mechanism where people can choose
themselves and if enough people want to
have uh solar or wind or whatever type
of renewable energy then that energy
will flourish without additional
subsidies
uh follow up but I'll remind members
that we're not here to discuss
philosophy we're here to ask questions
about the specifics of the bill this
would be a specific question about the
mechanism that you're mentioning you say
the mechanism is already in place but
your bill would actually you know
basically gut it uh by by capping those
uh those you know the percentage
requirements uh under the RPS the
mechanism is there for a reason and your
bill would gut it so how can you then
say that the bill you I think it
confused the bill wouldn't got it at all
but the requirement with the president
with the law was is it said that you
could simply go to your default energy
supplier which would be let's just say
eversource for the sake of example and
say I request that my electricity be 100
renewable and then they would come back
to you and say okay we can do that we're
going to make sure we buy enough
renewable energy to cover all the people
that request that and oh there's going
to be an extra charge involved in it and
it has nothing to do with renewable
portfolio standard these numbers as
amended in my Bill wouldn't change
whatsoever the eversource would still be
required to get six percent of their
electricity from class one Rex now some
of that would go to cover those requests
but if they had more requests than six
percent they would simply have to buy
more than six percent they couldn't buy
less
okay additional questions from the
committee representative muns
thank you Mr chair and um I'm sorry I
missed the uh the conversation on HB 165
so you may have answered that at my
question at that time
um oh okay sorry
um it was very short the um I guess I
guess given everything that you that you
were talking about why specifically
eliminating class three
well I didn't eliminate the class three
I put it at one percent because maybe
that's from part of the other uh the uh
thing there's a it's already in statute
that the department of energy has the
authority to adjust the class III Rex
requirement because we simply don't have
enough power plants to produce the
amount of power that was originally in
there which is at the six percent level
these are these are you have to remember
it's a very unusual rule because the
power plant had to go online prior to
nine 2006 I believe so if someone were
to come up with some new super duper uh
method of burning wood you could get 35
thermal efficiency it still wouldn't
replace the old clunker plants because
we're stuck having to buy Power for them
from ever be like saying 10 of the
computers bought by the state have to be
manufactured before 2010. it really
doesn't make much sense but the one
percent there reflects what can be
produced and that was actually just
reflects what was set by the doe because
they have the flex ability to lower that
when the amount of Supply goes down so
otherwise you'd just be buying alternate
compliance payments
follow up
further questions representative closure
and thank you chairman Bulls uh thank
you representative Harrington taking my
question have you factored in
the capital that businesses most most
Municipal and hospitals have purchased
wood boilers uh based on
the wrecks they would get
have I specifically done that no but I
also would say the reason for this why
this bill does doesn't take that into
consideration is because that's a
handout that's that's large yes from the
government in the rate payers that they
got they have no reason to believe that
that goes on forever any more than if I
started collecting unemployment and two
years later the government said well
sorry you can't collect it anymore
because I'm counting on that money now
you got to keep giving it me forever
it's the same thing no one should count
on getting a government grant that never
ends
additional questions for representative
Harrington
representative Wendy Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair
um yeah I know that thing is always
right there
um excuse me um online page one online
15 16 17.
you reduce the the goal for class one
um significantly
and you reduce class three to one
percent and you leave class four at the
same can you um can you explain why
sure the easy one would be the class
three because like I said that's already
been set to one percent by the
department of energy who has that
statutory authority to match it with the
demand upward Supply uh the other ones
simply I it's it minimizes it when we
say it limits the subsidy but it doesn't
eliminate it rather than going to 15 and
and point seven percent it keeps its it
puts it at six and point three which
means existing facilities and new
facilities will still get subsidies from
the rate payers through Rex but they
just won't get as bigger ones but at the
same time if you're looking at new ones
especially they will be eligible for
part of these billions and billions of
dollars coming from the federal
government that should induce people to
build all the Renewable Power we could
possibly cite in New Hampshire
follow up follow up excuse me thank you
um so you you came to these numbers
based on your opinion or was there any
research well it was based on my opinion
obviously it's just I think that's
enough that certainly giving them this
this continues the subsidy that we were
told if you remember I don't know how
long you've been dealing with Renewable
Power but we were told back when these
things were proposed that this was just
a bridge to get them over that initial
thing so when when wind production get
up into the thousands of megawatts they
wouldn't need any subsidies anymore on
the same with solar but of course once
somebody gets a subsidy they never want
to give it up this is just an attempt to
limit that it doesn't eliminate it it
just says this is enough thank you
representative Corman has a question
thank you Mr chairman uh thank you Mr
Harrington uh representative Harrington
oh I've been called worse don't worry
I think we all have
so I just want to make sure I understand
about uh the class three reduction to
one percent you're saying that Doe
already has set it to one percent yes in
20 and we're jumping if I'm wrong 2020
in 2021 they were given the statutory
Authority because it was there's a group
of I can't remember the original number
it was like six or seven small plants
they're all under 25 megawatts they all
went online prior to uh 2006. those were
the ones that were covered under class
three and I think all but one of them is
closed so we basically there was a law
was passed that allowed the puc doe now
to move that uh requirement down simply
because there wasn't enough Supply
because the plants didn't exist anymore
follow up
follow up so
I mean you say that's in statute but
wouldn't that statute be in Conflict
then with uh 362 F 3 which says eight
percent
well I'm changing okay it's it's in two
places the statute allows them the
authority to make the change which
they've already done and I'm simply
matching in this to go along with the
with what they've already said at one
percent
they still would have the authority to
adjust that
no not this one the other Statue I don't
have the number off the top of my head
that's that's how they made it one
percent
okay seeing no further questions thank
you
thank you representative Harrington I'd
like like excuse me I think there was a
question over here oh
representative brezhny has a question
thank you chairman
um this was a follow-up from a previous
question about where the number six
percent and point three percent for
class 1 and Class 2 came from and I
believe representative Harrington said
that it was from his opinion uh I just
wanted to clarify are you it is you
these numbers came
um because their continuation of 2015
right yeah that's not correct number as
okay seeing no further hands raised no
further questions I'd like next to call
to the front of the room
our
yes
so everyone's clear that section three
of the bill will be removed via
Amendment
okay because that's not necessary
anymore
uh Griffin Robards from the Department
uh thank you uh chairman Vos members of
the committee again Griffin Roberge from
the New Hampshire Department of energy
um the department is neutral on House
Bill 166.
um as introduced the bill makes three
primary changes to the state's RPS
policy
sections one two three and five remove
references to useful thermal energy
under the RPS that is a defined term in
the RPS statute
within class one of the RPS there is a
subset called class 1 thermal for
thermal Technologies so the removal of
that language indicates that uh class
one thermal will no longer be a subset
of class 1 under the RPS sec section 2
reduces the various obligations for
class 1 classes one and two uh based on
the look at the bill it appears to cap
them at 2015 obligation levels and then
class three's obligation is capped at
the 2021 level that was arrived at by
the department of energy when it's
statutorily adjusted the classes
obligation per the authority that we
have the repeal on lines 19 to 26 on
page one eliminate language that allows
for obligation increases to those
classes up to 20 up to the year 2025
and then section three eliminates
existing biomass facilities from
eligibility in class three and makes it
primarily an existing methane uh class
uh under the RPS
um just by a high level overview of
these changes uh the removal of useful
thermology from the RPS will will remove
the need for electric suppliers to
procure class 1 thermal Rex and also to
make acps for that class
based on our analysis you know a change
like this will certainly make an impact
to the low-grade wood Market here in New
Hampshire as well as to the residential
and Commercial
residential and commercial industrial
rebate programs for wood pellet systems
operated by the department we do
acknowledge that this will likely reduce
overall RPS compliance costs by an
indeterminable amount the reduction of
class obligations in class 2 will likely
lower the amount of wrecks that electric
suppliers need to get in classes one and
two with the rate of the proposed
reductions and the class one two credit
mechanism that we previously discussed
earlier this morning it is likely that
electric suppliers will be able to meet
this new RPS obligation under this bill
at lower levels by purchasing Rex
reducing the need for suppliers to make
acps to the renewable energy fund
therefore again likely to result in
lower RPS compliance costs but also a
subsequent reduction in renewable energy
funding for rebates and grants as well
and then the elimination of the existing
biomass facilities from eligibility in
class three
um will likely follow a similar policy
path that's been uh kind of articulated
in other states in the region like
Massachusetts and Connecticut that are
either trying to remove or phase out
biomass
um resources from the renewable
portfolio standards
um as with the removal of this subset
this class one thermal the removal of
biomass from class three you know will
likely impact low-grade wood markets
here in New Hampshire as well again that
class will only largely constitute
existing my uh methane resources
um and with that that really concludes
my testimony I'm happy to take any
questions that folks might have thank
you Mr chairman
thank you Mr Roberts so do we have
questions for the DOE
representative Corman has a question
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question so you mentioned um
that Massachusetts and was it
Connecticut are have um what what is it
they've done about
um about biomass sure so thank you for
the question so Massachusetts has
undertaken the uh policy decision to
remove uh it's my understanding remove
or in some way make it more difficult
for biomass facilities to qualify for
their renewable portfolio standards so
it's very difficult for those resources
to sell any wrecks that they generate
into the Massachusetts RPS market in
terms of Connecticut it's my
understanding and talking with our
sustainable energy division that
Connecticut is looking at phasing out
biomass uh resources from their State's
RPS one of the leading things that we've
seen in recent years is the rate by
which
RPS States set their alternative
compliance payments for biomass
facilities and I'm going to try to
unpack that a little bit so
Connecticut's is Connecticut's
alternative compliance payment for class
3 is slightly higher than New
Hampshire's is and because of that you
see a lot of electric suppliers settling
their class 3 or biomass wrecks in the
Connecticut Market to satisfy that
obligation to prevent paying these
higher cost acps
and they are instead paying the lower
cost acps here in New Hampshire so
um
that's at least the leading cause that
you
as to why we're seeing a a recent
increase in acps being made in class
three here in New Hampshire
um
I hope that made sense I'm sorry it's a
lot to throw right yeah right yeah
follow up follow up
so these changes in Massachusetts I
guess those have happened the ones in
Connecticut are pending it sounds like I
believe so and I I again had a word out
to our sustainable energy division but
uh some staffers have been out sick and
so the response there so my question is
are these in statute or are these more
uh regulatory thank you for the question
so this is I guess the nature of the
regional RPS Market is that every state
determines their own respective RPS
policies and any changes to those
policies have an impact on the entire
Regional RPS market so if Massachusetts
decides biomass will not qualify for our
RPS anymore then biomass facilities are
comparable wrecks and that might be
eligible in other states can no longer
sell into Massachusetts anymore if
Connecticut makes changes to its ACP
rate and it incentivizes biomass
facilities to sell their wrecks there
that has an impact to say New Hampshire
where we're not getting the comparable
wrecks wrecks being settled here and
acps are being made by electric
suppliers so
in a nutshell different states and their
policy decisions have implications for
representative Reynolds asked a question
thank you Mr chairman
isn't there a large difference in the
combustion efficiency of biomass
combustion for electricity generation in
small plants like you were just talking
about and the combustion efficiency that
um
for a um for a facility to qualify for
thermal wrecks so if I could thank you
for the question so if I could break it
down a little further you're talking
about I guess a larger biomass facility
versus say a residential like wood
pellet boiler system you're talking
about correct yes I'm talking about wood
pellet boiler yep and New Hampshire is
the only state that has thermal racks
correct
and the other kind of uh wrecks and RPS
you're talking about is
the combustion of wood in large electric
generating correct stations yep that's
correct isn't there a large difference
in combustion efficiency in those two
facilities I would agree with that yes
can you give us a sense I I would I
would just agree with that in in I
couldn't provide specific data to back
that up I just know yeah I I I'd be
reluctant to do that I I can certainly
follow up with a sustainable energy
division here in our department but I
don't want to get into the okay the
numbers but I know that that in Broad
Strokes is true okay thank you
representative Kaplan has a question
thank you Mr chair
um I know your department is you know
has an overarching concern with costs as
you define costs and I don't want to
debate that because that would Veer into
philosophy and I'm not going to do that
but
um I didn't I don't hear you uh give any
analysis of the impact of this bill on
the diversifying the diversity and the
future diversity of Our Generation mix
and so I'm wondering if you have any
insight into whether this bill might
impact on that diversity of generation
mix going forward and how that might
impact on costs sure and uh thank you
for the question so you know if you
review the purpose statement that's in
the RPS statute is that one of the
leading
legislative policy goals of the RPS is
to encourage the diversification of
energy sources here in the state the RPS
is a policy to to do that
um by lessening I guess uh the impact by
lessening the obligations
um for these uh various Technologies
under the RPS
does have the potential of
I would say in two fronts is that
it it could be taken as a way of maybe I
I want disincentivizing or not
incentivizing renewable energy resources
for one but two could also uh
introduce maybe a level of Market
uncertainty as I was addressing
representative corman's question you
know as states make substantial changes
to their RPS uh policies that can have a
ha that can shape the regional RPS
so at the beginning of this hearing I
asked you all to imagine that it lasted
for a half an hour
well half hour is gone and we still have
and yet we wash the car and now it's
going to rain okay
any more questions for Mr Roberts yes
representative muns
thank you Mr chair
um do we have any idea what the actual
percentages are of
um total megawatts supplied
by class
thank you for the question so the
obligations or the percentages required
to be Pro the required under States is
spelled out in State Statute so
um what was it I know the reference
references made earlier about the
department exercising its authority to
adjust the obligation for class three we
also have that same object uh we also
have that same Authority for class four
which is existing Hydro as well based on
2022 compliance year the total RPS
compliance for all classes is 22.50
percent
um and I can certainly provide uh uh
something on that from our website that
kind of spells that out if you'd like I
can go through each class but I realize
we're running over time here and
follow-up
follow up
um it it would be great if you could
break it out by class because it it it
kind of begs the question that if the
actual for example of class one is
already at 10 why would we go back to
six I'll I'll run through it quite
quickly then thank you for the question
uh class one
just class one as a whole and this is
again based on calendar year 2022 is
10.30 percent
and then the total class one obligation
is at 12.30 so that's a combination of
the 10.30 and the two percent
class two is at point seven zero percent
class three is at eight percent
currently
class four is at one point five zero
percent
and I can follow up with an email to the
committee that spells that out further
that would be great thanks
okay seeing no further questions for Mr
Roberge we will now move on and call to
the all right front of the room Mr
Michael O'Leary who represents
Bridgewater power
uh thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee my name is Michael O'Leary I'm
the asset manager of Bridgewater Power
Company
Bridgewater is one of the uh five
remaining smaller biomass plants in the
state where 15 megawatt biomass plant
um
I've testified before the committee many
times in the past and outlined the
benefits of biomass power
such as jobs in the rural economy
forestry benefits fuel diversity
capacity and diversity benefits in ISO
New England
Etc so I won't
go into great detail on those but would
be happy to try to answer questions if
necessary Bridgewater employees
20 people and we have a direct payroll
and benefits of over 2.3 million dollars
so it's pretty important in our little
area of the state
we purchase over five million dollars a
year of wood fuel chips
also quite important in our area of the
state
to qualify for class III wrecks our
facility has to meet air emissions
requirements that a 66 percent below our
permitted requirements
so the RPS clearly has societal benefits
of Clean Air
we could be online producing at 66
percent higher emissions
uh to produce Rex as a cost to a power
plant like Bridgewater first off we had
to put in Capital Equipment
we have operating costs of over a half a
megawatt
in parasitic load to run the fan
horsepower that's required to run the
Catalyst we have ammonia expense
to take our nox emission and turn it
into the benign compounds of
nitrogen and water
we've sold more than 90 percent of our
wrecks
out of state
so have borne no
cost to New Hampshire rate payers and
all if you look at the bill and you look
at uh some of the things that
representative Harrington has
characterized they're simply not
accurate
the puc has the ability each year
to lower
the the RPS standard
we have been quite transparent with the
puc last year as a matter of fact for
2022 I testified yes go ahead and lower
the standard the requirement because we
don't need the program we've sold them
out of state you can reduce the ACP
payments and we've done that repeatedly
since 2007. that's why you've seen the
requirement go down but we've always
said we need the placeholder of the
eight percent because there will become
a day when we're going to be dependent
on New Hampshire class 3 wrecks
state of Connecticut
it has nothing to do with pollution
it has to do with being provincial
and not wanting to send Connecticut rate
payer dollars to New Hampshire
so you can still qualify for renewable
energy credits if you built a new
biomass power plant in Connecticut
but they're phasing out
the older Legacy biomass plants because
they didn't like the fact that all their
ratepayer dollars were going to New
Hampshire and have and have come here
for many many years
so in 20 this is the absolute wrong time
to lower the standard from the eight
percent to one percent
in statute because the puc has the
authority they review it every year as
as the gentleman from doe just said 2023
it's at eight percent
they haven't opened the docket yet to
determine what it will be they'll review
the market
they'll evaluate how many megawatts are
available in the market
they'll they'll ask for Testimony
they'll ask for testimony from the
utilities whether the utilities have
been able to procure wrecks or not be
able been able to procure Rex and then
they'll make a determination and they've
and they've done that every year since
2007.
um
Massachusetts the same way they're not
it's not because of a pollution issue
it's because of
not wanting Massachusetts dollars to
flow to New Hampshire
EPA U.S EPA and the ipcc International
Panel for climate change
have both completely kind of
unequivocally agreed that biogenic
carbon is a completely different animal
than fossil carbon
that they're looking they look at the
two of the difference between 10 000
plus years of tied up carbon versus a
50-year type tied up carbon so it's that
that's that's been clear science that
I'm not a climate scientist and and
don't want to debate that issue but it's
I I think that we have the facts on on
that and it's been studied uh quite a
bit
um
happy to really try to answer any other
questions
on the rec programs in the other state
or on class three but but a plant like
Bridgewater we we really have three
revenue streams we sell energy the
physical kilowatt hours we sell capacity
and then we sell the renewable energy
credits and without all three
we're out of business so we're dependent
upon the New Hampshire class 3 Program
um and it's I think it's been a very
successful program
and I think the plans have been a
thank you very enlightening testimony we
appreciate you being here to deliver it
we have questions for Mr O'Leary from
seeing none thank you
and next call to the front of the
building
or to the table rather Mr Charlie
nibbling who is representing himself
he's from boscoin and someone who's
testified before this Committee in the
past welcome
thank you Mr nibbling
foreign
members of the health science technology
and energy committee
it's uh a pleasure to come before you
today to defend
the importance of recognizing renewable
thermal energy in the New Hampshire
renewable portfolio standard
I'm pleased once again to have this
opportunity
I've prepared some written testimony
which I have have printed in in this
distrib Distributing I'm not going to
read it I will paraphrase
a few items briefly and then I wanted to
speak to representative Harrington's uh
assertion that
uh
an electric RPS is no place to
incentivize renewable thermal energy and
I'm sorry
that representative Harrington is not
here to to listen to my comments
um
my history with thermal and the RPS goes
back to 2006.
when Governor Benson formed a study
committee to evaluate the adoption of an
RPS that led to House Bill 873 in 2007
it was sent to interim study it was
passed in 2008 and it became effective
in 2009 with the adoption of Rules by
the puc
there was quite a bit of discussion at
that time about a more fuel and
Technology neutral renewable energy
standard one that embraced both both
electricity and thermal
but the legislature stopped short of
doing that with a couple notable
exceptions one they made the renewable
energy fund Fuel and Technology neutral
they made it possible for that fund to
support renewable thermal Technologies
two it's set in motion a study by the
Public Utilities Commission which was
completed in 2010 evaluating the
efficacy of adding thermal to the RPS
that that study was published and the
puc
stopped short of a recommendation but
instead it said it's feasible that
recommendation became codified and
Senate Bill 218 in 2012 which came
before this committee chaired at the
time by representative Jim Garrity
that was a time when both the House and
Senate were under Republican leadership
the house by uh speaker Bill O'Brien
that bill passed the house 275 to 6.
adding thermal to the RPS passed the
Senate unanimously and became effective
upon passage and ultimately with the
adoption of rules
New Hampshire was the first state to add
thermal to its RPS in a comprehensive
Fuel and Technology neutral manner
uh since then 15 states have added
thermal in one form or another to their
RPS programs and to the question I
believe that representative Summers
asked earlier while Massachusetts no
longer recognizes biomass in its RPS it
does in its alternative portfolio
standard the aps
recognizes biomass thermal
making the policy decision to
foreclose on future biomass electric
generation has fully embraced thermal
generation
main added thermal to its RPS in 2019
Vermont debated a clean heat standard
last year that was ultimately vetoed by
governor Scott but is coming back again
uh apparently as a result of
negotiations between the governor's
office and the legislature and they're
going to take another run at it so yeah
if you look to the south in New England
where there essentially is no Forest
products industry left
uh
they have taken steps to eliminate or
reduce support for biomass energy but if
you look to the north the East and the
West they have fully embraced biomass
energy in their RPS programs
um
I I've cited some statistics here Mr
chairman that are based on the 63
facilities that are thermal wreck
eligible in the state since the the
rules were adopted in 2014 I won't
recite those
and I did want to speak to
representative Harrington's question
or assertion that an electric RPS that
it's not appropriate to have electric
gray pairs
um
incentivizing renewable thermal
Technologies
there are five responses to that
question the first is thermal meets all
of the public purposes of the RPS
whether it's fuel diversity rural
Economic Development emissions reduction
it meets all of those objectives
which is why the idea of a more fuel and
Technology neutral
energy policy is a good thing to to
pursue
secondly it does so at significantly
lower cost
and it's important to note that I think
the main reason
Senate Bill 218 passed in 2012 was
because of the way the thermal provision
was structured it was structured as a
carve out of the pre-existing class one
obligation it took a piece of the class
1 electric obligation with an ACP of 55
and it allocated it to Thermal at an ACP
of 25 so by that single uh decision it
significantly reduced the overall
compliance uh cost of the RPS
and I believe that's the only reason it
passed in at that time given the uh uh
the
um perspective of those who are in
charge of the legislature at the time
third uh it has the potential to
significantly reduce demand for natural
gas in the winter time if people switch
from natural gas to a renewable thermal
technology that takes pressure albeit
small
off demand for natural gas during those
periods in the winter time when you have
constrained demand and you see Peak
pricing for natural gas
fourth
all electric rate pairs are heat
consumers all electric repairs have the
potential directly or indirectly to
benefit from the thermal provisions of
the RPS and fifth uh and I've stated
this and I'll state it again it's helped
to move energy policy in the state
toward a more fuel and Technology
neutral platform
uh we we consume roughly a third of all
energy consumed in this in the state is
heat
roughly a third electricity roughly a
third transportation
so by this decision to add thermal we
we created a policy that Embraces
two-thirds of the energy consumption in
the state directly or indirectly
that's it Mr chairman I'd be happy to
answer any questions
um
uh historical or or based on current
practice
and I would ask the committee to vote
this bill in expedient to legislate
thank you
thank you very Illuminating testimony we
appreciate you being here and offering
both your historical and Industry
perspective on this question
representative Wendy Thomas has a
question for you thank you Mr chair
um this list of business of um accounts
I should say or
um projects that that are thermal
projects if they lost the ability to get
wrecks how would that um affect them
financially
well uh Rex are trading for somewhere
between 20 and 25 a megawatt hour
thermal Rex
so depending on the number of wrecks
that they generate and
and are authorized to sell
uh to
uh qualified buyers that represents in
some cases very significant revenue
streams to those
those generators and to varying degrees
they made Investments contingent on the
expectation that those revenues would
continue either to pay down Debt Service
on the capital cost of their
installation or to reduce their
operating costs
thank you and thank you for moving that
um speaker
representative Reynolds has a question
well thank you Mr chairman my question
was along the same lines I guess I just
would ask you instead of repeating um
exactly the same question
um to comment on the list you've given
us a list of current
um
facilities current institutions that
have biomass boilers
actually a number of them are geothermal
systems as well okay okay
um it
surveying the list it appears that the
overwhelming majority of them are public
sector institutions of some sort schools
counties municipalities
um
is there a reason for that and and like
is there a phenomenon this is a
cost-saving measure for well those are
when you say public their
taxpayer-funded entities and
taxpayer-funded entities have a a duty
to their
residents and taxpayers to make prudent
financial decisions about long-term
costs that are ultimately borne by
taxpayers heating is is a significant
expense for a public school system
uh County Nursing Home facility a rural
non-profit Hospital
um
they're in a better position I think in
many cases to make significant Capital
Investments knowing that they will
realize a return on that investment say
after 8 10 12 14 years
businesses on the other hand need a more
immediate return on investment to
justify capital investment
so projects that that don't uh
generate simple paybacks of three to
five years usually are not considered by
businesses
thank you
uh I would remind members to turn your
microphone off when you're finished
speaking uh representative Summers has a
question
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
clarifying the question I asked earlier
I appreciate that
um one question I have is uh
in this bill about subsidies now granted
we all know subsidies are not supposed
to last forever and so with the goal in
mind of uh is there a revenue point or
something you shouldn't afford to where
you would not or where would not there
would need to have subsidies would no
longer have to exist
well
um the thermal provision actually
plateaus out into the plateaued out in
so the thermal carve out subclass if you
will no longer grows after 2022
if additional projects are seeking to
qualify their systems for thermal racks
eventually the supply of wrecks will
exceed what the statute requires the
utilities and competitive suppliers to
purchase Supply will exceed demand
prices of wrecks will come down
significantly
that's the way it's structured now and
that was intentional I believe when
Senate Bill 218 was passed it doesn't
last forever it plateaus out
and as Supply continues to grow over
time eventually Rec values will come
down and the incentive value of that
representative cloje has a question
thank you Mr chairman fols and thank you
for taking my question I've seen the
list here of thermal how many
operational
plants are
excuse me
how many plants were operational
for electrical generation I realized
Springfield Ashland and Bethlehem Tam
were I might not know them all but I
believe only two are producing
um a generation of electricity by
thermal I believe that's correct a
Bridgewater which Mr O'Leary spoke to
and the Burgess plant in Berlin are
still operational those are that's
electric generation not not thermal
follow-up
thank you chairman Bulls uh follow up
the other ones that I mentioned is
probably more
you mentioned cost it's cheaper to use
thermal
but
producing electricity
your is it cheaper I'd like to know than
other sources
other sources being other renew
renewable energy sources or
go ahead and explain
that's thank you uh I my apologies of
other fields natural gas oil okay um
for making electricity
um I'd like to defer to either Mr stock
or perhaps you'd invite Mr O'Leary back
okay so you know further questions I
want to thank you for thank you Mr
chairman uh excellent testimony we
appreciate you being here and now I'll
call
Mr Jason stock to the table he's been
waiting a long time
came here to testify on the previous
bill
we've made him earn his salary today I
think
[Music]
foreign
I put three minutes but that was for two
bills so we have one minute we have one
bill so I'm going to try to do it in a
minute and a half
um for the record my name is Jason stock
I'm the executive director of the New
Hampshire Timberland Owners Association
we represent the state's Timberland
owners and the forest products industry
um our members owner manage about a
million acres of land across the state
we have just over a thousand members in
our membership and it's the entire food
chain
um
and I've come today in opposition to in
opposition to this bill
and I wanted to explain to you briefly
kind of the Nexus between
utility policy and natural resource
management policy and I also wanted to
talk a little bit about carbon and and
as it relates there's been some
questions about carbon and as it relates
to biomass and biomass constr combustion
um
in your packet you have a copy of our
our latest magazine which which timing
is everything actually this Edition is
dedicated to carbon and in in climate
change and and uh use of forest and
carbon markets Etc so I wanted to
provide you a copy of that that also
gives you an idea of who we are
um I also included in the packet a UNH
this is just the executive summary
Forest products industry economic
contribution
States Forest Products Industries about
2.5 billion dollars
um and that's all sectors of which
biomass is a part of
um
and
across the state you have a and you have
a copy of this also
they're about two thousand two hundred
and twenty six Timber sales occurred
across the entire State according to the
last Timber tax data for the last tax
year in every County and almost every
town and what I want to point out is
that about two-thirds when you look at
Forest Service survey data about
two-thirds of all the wood that's
growing on our landscape is considered
low grade this is wood that cannot be
converted in or sown into a into a it's
a two by four or piece of wood for for a
desk and so for for landowners and land
managers the ability to manage their
property it's just like your garden you
need a plate you need to do that weeding
and thinning you need a market for
low-grade wood biomass has been
historically a part of that market for
our state
um and it's been a very important part
um we have currently two power plants
running as you heard earlier uh Burgess
and Bridgewater there were four that
were idle they've just come out of
bankruptcy
um and they are starting up running one
is in Springfield and one is in
Whitefield why I mentioned this is that
percentage when we look at that eight
percent why this is important
the puc and the doe have the discretion
to to modify that percentage as plants
come and go offline as they sell wrecks
out of the state we have this I'll call
it a a safety valve that allows them to
modify the the class III obligation and
so that's built that's already baked
into law and so just to reduce it to one
percent removes that flexibility as a
power plant comes on or as as you heard
earlier is a power plant says all right
New Hampshire is the market I need to I
need to be participating in
oh
the other piece of this uh these power
plants they burn wood chips a number of
you toured the Bridgewater plant earlier
this year
you'll see chips come in from across the
state also our Sawmill industry when you
take a round log and you make it Square
Lumber those slabs get chipped
as does the bark that is those those
products need a home a typical eastern
white pine Mill can produce up to 11
tractor-trailer loads of these chips
and biomass plants have been a very very
good Market to to manage that manage
that Mill waste if I can just interrupt
you for one second for anyone who's here
to hear House Bill 81 which was
scheduled to be heard at eight at 3 30.
we will start that public Hearing in
about 10 maybe 15 minutes as soon as we
finish this one thank you
so
may I
oh so so
um so I guess I just in all the details
are in our Our Testimony all the numbers
all the statistics it's a these plants
are important the thermal creates a new
opportunity or has created a new
opportunity for both Municipal savings
as well as markets for low-grade and as
well as local jobs and the beauty of it
is it's a local homegrown energy source
that comes here and employs employs
people in the state
the question
I want to kind of conclude my testimony
to get to this question of
sustainability carbon
Etc
New Hampshire's we nhtoa and as you
heard earlier EPA have concluded biomass
is is sustainable and in terms of carbon
neutrality I would I would strongly
argue that it is and you have to look no
further than the usda's forest service
data that shows in the state of New
Hampshire we grow more wood than is
harvested or dies of natural mortality
so even with our power plants running
and our Sawmills We are continuing to
accrue Carbon on the landscape as our
through our forest that doesn't include
the carbon that's stored in this desk so
this question about is biomass
environmentally is it an environmentally
friendly or or carbon-friendly energy
source the proof is right here the the
you have to look no further than that I
also included the this it's kind of
cartoonish but it's from our friends at
the USDA this biogenic versus
geologic carbon
uh uh handout to kind of illustrate that
what we're talking about is a carbon
cycle that circulates
the thing in New Hampshire unlike
Western States our issue is not planting
trees our issue is controlling growth
and what I mean by that is we continue
to grow more wood
we continue you go in and do a a
clear-cut
it grows back I tell folks don't mow
your lawn for a couple years and see
what happens you will get trees
um it's it's and we are we are very
fortunate to be in that situation
so again
um as a as an industry this this RPS law
is a classic intersection between policy
utility policy natural resource
management and I would dare say rural
economics rural economics
we Plymouth state did an analysis
economic analysis each log truck or chip
van that goes down the road there are 15
this was done in 2014
at that time the value economic activity
to get that truck from the log Landing
to either the power plant or the
Sawmills fifteen hundred dollars is
economic activity that's Timber taxes
paid to towns that's logger salary
that's fuel that's diesel fuel that's
used for the truck and the skidder so
for us this is a big issue
this is why we when we look at House
Bill 165 and 166 earlier or 166 and 165
earlier this is why we've come today to
speak in opposition I'd be happy to try
and answer any questions and if folks
want more information I can bury you in
it from from EPA and the USDA
thank you wonderful information
I will allow questions but I'll remind
members that we have five more pink
cards here for this public hearing
representative Wendy Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair
um just in your written testimony um at
the bottom of page one you say
unfortunately due to the nature of our
Timber types and soils two-thirds of our
forests are growing low-grade Timber
has that has it always been like that or
has something changed recently it's it's
always been around that
um it's the nature we don't owe we don't
grow Sequoias or big beautiful Douglas
Firs we grow Twisted we love all our
trees but you know look at a red maple
look at a birch tree a lot of them are
just it's just the nature of how they
grow if you can get one saw log out of
that consider yourself lucky
um the rest of it you either chip or you
try to find you know cut it up for
firewood
oh thank you representative Corman has a
question
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question I haven't had a
chance to actually read your written
testimony but uh do you have any
estimate for the impact on on the labor
market in the forestry industry or the
the economic impact in terms of dollars
should this bill pass
we do I mean we we there has been there
has been economic analysis done and I
can I can provide you some information I
didn't bring it with me today but when
we look at when we look at the states
and you look at this economic report the
forest products industry employs about
12 000 individuals directly and
indirectly
biomass is part of this interconnected
supply chain
so you say all right we're going to
remove biomass we pass this bill these
plants close
okay you say well that's Mike's 20
people in his in his yard well that
affects the loggers that delivered there
that affects the Sawmills that took
would take their chips there so this
this ripple effect and there was some
analysis done
um a couple years ago that I I'm happy
to provide to the committee that tries
representative closure has a question
thank you chairman Boltz and a real
quick uh thank you for taking my
question certainly
um
on
pests like the pine bore and all the
combustion of this low-grade wood do you
know if it had is anything out there
the effect of this on the yeah that's a
great question
um that's one of the benefits of biomass
is its ability to completely destroy it
um emerald ash borer we have emerald ash
borer chewing up our ash trees now you
have an infestation
you need to get rid of that rid of that
material and want to try to control it
biomass is a is a great way to do that
state of Massachusetts had a What's
called the Asian longhorn beetle and
especially nasty little bug in the
Worcester area they had to do a uh kind
of a very strategic strategic
containment process and the all the
folks with the USDA
Forest pest group said you have to burn
this wood because that's the only way we
can ensure that this pest is in fact
eliminated if you were just to take the
bark off it you run the risk that one of
these eggs or one of these little larvae
continue to continue to live and infest
okay seeing no further questions I'd
like to call on the next individual who
would like to speak to us and that's
Mark frowling of throwing energy and
Keen
welcome mark
thank you so much
um Mr Bose and thank you committee
members
my name is Mark froling I own and
operate a biomass boiler company in
Keene New Hampshire
and um I have
um
produced quite a few uh boiler
installations over the last 10 years
that are contributing to generating
these wrecks and that has been the
number one reason why I have sold these
boiler plants so my business has greatly
benefited in the past from these wrecks
that were instituted a few years ago and
driven quite a bit of business based on
these wrecks being available
um but more than that because that is in
the past and that's not what this bill
is addressing because it's keeping the
past in place but
um I have currently
um you know my sales cycle because I'm
proud predominantly in the public sector
selling to counties to nursing homes
jails and police facilities and things
like that and also Public Schools I have
about 17 projects that are in the queue
over the next couple of years and
they're all counting on these wrecks and
um I don't think many of these projects
go would go forward if these wrecks
weren't available
it's a really really important part of
sort of our overall system people in the
meantime that are interested in in
biomass boilers
that are generating or can generate
these thermals wrecks they're really
counting on that wreck Revenue to
finance their system they don't always
get grants capped for the capital and so
they finance them over the time through
these wrecks and it's been just a
tremendous benefit to to these owners or
the new potential owners but if that
goes away it would be a real dilemma for
my business because I really have not
sold any
um reasonable size boilerplants without
the Rex not a single one because the Rex
drive that business and so it's quite
important to me to keep these wrecks in
place and I greatly oppose this bill
and if anybody has any questions
um
I'm happy to answer
thank you representative partial has a
question
thank you chair votes and thank you for
coming today
um can you tell me approximately I have
had the pleasure of turning your plant
can you tell me approximately about how
many people you directly employ in your
plant and maybe give me an idea of an
economic impact to the Keen area
yeah so we have
um 15 direct employees and with a
payroll of 875 000 you know for last
year
and um then indirectly of course we have
truckers that provide us from other
Sawmills that provide us the materials
and truckers that sometimes
um you know send material out
um there's a lot of subcontractors
through that business there's
um mechanical construction outfits that
we hire and so indirectly you know I
don't know how large that envelope is
but it's quite significant we drive
between three and five million dollars
any given year depending on how things
going right now it's actually a great
time for biomass because in general
energy has gone quite High the cost of
energy has gone up quite a bit and so
biomass it being a very affordable
you know energy
um is really having its Heyday right now
and sort of pulling the rug out under it
this would be the worst possible time
absolutely the worst possible time I
cannot see how this house bill was
really thought through doesn't make
sense to me um why why you would kind of
pull this
um support out when it's really a good
time to support it and make this all
work
so I have a question yeah
did I understand you to say that
the 17 projects you have in your queue
would not go forward without
thermal wrecks I can't speak on behalf
of my customers because I don't make
their decisions but if I told them that
the wrecks weren't available coming into
the future
um here for the next couple years they
um
I don't know how many projects would go
forward but very few because I really
frankly have not sold any projects in
that size range of course we sell
residential projects they don't utilize
the wrecked Market but on the large
scale where we go into a school they
absolutely make this work with the
public because it's always funded by the
public on top of it of course through a
bond and things like that they see that
Revenue stream when the public sees
there's no support on that then it's
very difficult because it's just you
know
so even though the price of oil has gone
up substantially in the last year year
and a half it's still not economic to
convert to wood boilers without this
additional help is that it it's economic
but this wreck is a really nice steady
stream so when you have grants coming in
a one-time Grant during the construction
it's nice for sure nobody turns down a
good grant money but people really value
the long-term gra excuse me the
long-term money that goes with
generation and there's many reasons for
for why that is so valuable because it
also allows the plant to be always tuned
to the top efficiency because people
want to get the most amount of wrecks
out so it's sort of a self
um
governing
um system that works really well and so
we have of course benefited of it I'm
personally also generating wrecks in my
own plan to grind to dry trips myself
and and
um you know we are at 75 I know earlier
on Mr Harrington was saying that people
are generating thermal efficiencies of
30 that hasn't been done in forever I
think but really normal thermal
efficiencies of boilers these days are
between 70 for a steam boiler and 84 for
pellet boiler that is sort of where it's
at and if you're going Cogen like we do
um you know we're going kojan with steam
you can certainly be at 74 75 percent
so it's it's all very efficient and um
it's a good system and I would really
um
recommend to keep this in place okay we
don't need a sales pitch but
Representatives
no representative Reynolds doesn't have
a question
okay so you know further questions we
thank you for being here and next we'll
call on Nick
Krakoff of the conservation law
Foundation
good afternoon good afternoon Mr
chairman and honorable committee members
my name is Nick Krakoff with the
conservation law foundation and thank
you for the opportunity to testify today
the RPS benefits New Hampshire's economy
provides public health and environmental
benefits from New Hampshire and even
helps reduce energy rates for New
Hampshire's families and businesses
because HP 166 would severely weaken the
RPS I urge the committee to oppose this
bill
New Hampshire will be unable to fully
take advantage of the significant
economic benefits of Renewables that
this bill has passed specifically with
respect to provision or section number
two in the in the bill
um that but that provision would
severely weaken the RPS standard and the
RPS supports increased investments in
Renewables like solar and wind
and brings local renewable energy jobs
New Hampshire
and So to avoid New Hampshire losing out
on the development of a renewable energy
industry here while neighboring states
reap the benefits the committee should
really reject this bill
um as one of the testifiers spoke to
earlier one of the purposes of the RPS
is really to provide energy diversity
benefits
and so as we all know as we're aware New
Hampshire families and businesses are
suffering from high energy rates at the
moment and these rates are largely the
result of extremely high natural gas
prices you know natural gas prices are
extremely volatile and you know our
state and our region are you know
there's an over-dependence on natural
gas for power generation right now in
contrast the price of Renewables they
have a very they're inherently more
stable than fossil fuels and can um you
know it can even cost less than fossil
fuels I provided written testimony that
shows that Renewables are starting to be
cost competitive even can cost less than
fossil of yours in some instances and so
increased investments in RBS they
provide significant energy diversity
benefits which is one of the purposes of
the RPS statute and that can help
insulate families and businesses from
those volatile fossil fuel prices and
have a price suppressing effect on
electric rates
but HP 166 would just lead to New
Hampshire being more exposed to volatile
fossil fuel prices
and then finally the RPS provides public
health and environmental benefits
pollution from fossil fuels contributes
to asthma and other respiratory diseases
and increased use of Renewables is
important for addressing the climate
climate change
you know when New Hampshire is already
experiencing mild Winters and increased
coastal flooding from climate change
and so at a time we need to start
addressing climate change HP 166 would
be a step in the wrong direction and
disregard our responsibility for dealing
with that crisis so
um and it's um
the RPS is good for the economy for
diversity benefits and for the
environment public health and I urge the
committee to vote against this bill to
vote itl okay thank you happy to take
any questions
seeing no questions I thank you for your
testimony and turn to the next speaker
who will be Jim
Monahan from
who is representing the New Hampshire
Association of counties wearing
thank you Mr chairman I'm Jim Monahan
with the DuPont group uh and I'm wearing
my New Hampshire Association of County
hat uh this afternoon
um we appeared today in in opposition to
House Bill 166 and I'll be brief you all
have seen the list of facilities that
are included in the project that include
Five County facilities two in Chester
County as well as Merrimack Rockingham
and Sullivan County all many of you were
perhaps were on your served on your
delegations when the decisions were made
to cite these facilities as you all know
they penciled out because you had the
benefit of the uh the T-Rex as a part of
it so there's a lot of potential for
disruption uh to the county budgets in
the way they handle energy costs for the
county so I won't I'm certainly happy to
answer any questions you might have but
I think you've had a lot of testimony
today
okay see no one uh who wants to ask a
question I'll call the next
the pin up penultimate speaker on this
uh public hearing and that's Matt Leahy
and Mr Leahy
I'll be quick it would be nice if you
didn't repeat the information we've
already heard yeah no I I did submit
written testimony earlier I'm not going
to repeat that I just wanted to add one
comment and just sort of an add-on to
what Jason was saying about
uh low-grade wood markets you know that
connection between Forest management and
low-grade wooden markets so if you
remember last session the legislature
created
um the New Hampshire low-grade Timber
and wood Emerging Market commission uh
representative Thomas was the Prime
sponsor on that
um you know and one of the charges of
that commission was to look into
you know State policy that could benefit
or or create new or expand markets for
for low-grade wood and when we look at
um
thermal energy you know a locally
sourced thermal energy we we have a
solution to one of the questions that
this commission is looking at so we
would urge um
this committee to vote against House
Bill 166 because we think that there is
a market we have here for low-grade wood
I'll take any questions though
thank you do you serve on that
commission I do not no no
okay
good to know
all right seeing no questions from the
uh committee I'll Now call on our final
speaker I always like to give the last
word to Sam Evans Brown of clean energy
I think I'm frequently last on the list
because I'm frequently late uh and
arrive just on time to the start of the
hearing so my cards come in last
um thank you for the record I'm Sam
Evans Brown executive director of clean
energy New Hampshire we also are
testifying in opposition to this bill
all the reasons that are in my written
testimony which I'm happy to submit uh
in just a moment were laid out by
previous speakers so I will not repeat
them
um I think maybe the only point that I
would like to hammer home on is that
particularly the effect of reducing the
class one Rec requirement to the the
level that we have already achieved
achieved today will have the effect of
driving the value of renewable energy
credits down
ostensibly to the point where whatever
the market equilibrium is for that for
that wreck price is but close to zero
there are precious few policies that New
Hampshire has on the books that are
encouraging the construction of new
generation and it is very hard to build
anything in New Hampshire and I think it
has given our our current energy
situation we should be actively
encouraging the construction of new
generation and this is this is one of
the very few policies that's that's
doing that it's doing it in a
market-based way uh in a way that should
respond to Market forces and and achieve
a state of equilibrium once we have
built enough to to meet the RPS
requirements so with that I'll take any
questions if the committee has any
thank you for making that excellent
point
seeing no questions from the committee
we appreciate your being here and
testifying and with that I will close
the public hearing
on House Bill 166 and ask representative
closure to reveal the blue sheet
thank you chairman Bulls
H um House Bill 166 the blue sheet was
none in favor
nine opposed online two in favor 41
opposed
okay thank you we're going to go
immediately into a public hearing on
House Bill 81 establishing a study
committee to examine all ancillary
charges for propane gas sales and I'm
going to call up to the table the prime
sponsor of this proposed legislation
that's Rose representative Rosemary rung
of Hillsboro District 12.
thank you much thank you very much Mr
chairman and thank you to the committee
um last fall I got a email from a
constituent of mine who was very
concerned about practices he was or
problems he was experiencing with his
propane gas company
and he wanted me to pursue a legislative
remedy and not knowing how extensive
this problem was if it
was shared by other constituents I put
something on our community Facebook page
and I was very amazed at the response
and I've included some of those
responses in the written testimony I've
distributed but I'm certain there is a
pervasive problem with business
practices of several at least one
propane company operating in New
Hampshire and
um HB 81 would set up a study committee
of legislators to be able to collect
facts about the industry hear from
industry Representatives other
constituents to determine if a
legislative remedy is needed to address
what may be appear to be some very
unfair labor practices
the major ones I've heard of is
companies are charging rent on propane
tanks that the customer already owns
um or a customer may be calling a
company to want to switch providers and
the original company has to come and
take their tank and they just don't
respond so they continually charge rent
and fees and on the customer and really
making them unable to be able to switch
to a more affordable provider other
issues are um arbitrary minimum set to
get a discount
I don't know there's several other
issues and I just think it's
our responsibility to really understand
this issue and determine whether we need
to provide some consumer protection for
people who rely on propane for Home
Heating and I would be happy to answer
any questions you have
thank you and thank you for introducing
this bill I have a question for you on
my propane bill
about three or four years ago
there appeared a charge called the
safety fee it was 9.95
then a couple years later it went up to
12.95 I just got to fill up the other
day the safety fee is now up to 19.95.
is that one of the ancillary charges
that you want this committee to
investigate yes it would be and I'm
sorry to hear that chairman Vose
um yeah you'd be great if you could be
on the study committee uh if if this
passes but an ancillary charge is
considered any charge beyond the actual
price of the product so anything in
addition to the actual propane that's
being purchased
okay representative Doug Thomas has a
question
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question
um
has any action been taken to notify the
Attorney General to look into this issue
in terms of just questioning if he's had
complaints given to his department or
not in lieu of a study committee
um thank you very much for your question
um I included in my testimony a letter
that was sent
um by one of my constituents that did
follow up I haven't talked to the
Attorney General's office to find out if
they have been keeping a a summary of
the complaints that they've had but I do
know people have contacted them to
complain
further questions representative
Bernardi has a question
thank you Mr chairman so regarding uh
tank rental fees uh are you did you hear
complaints about those fees
uh being initially part of a
purchase or an agreement to buy gas from
a company and then being extended beyond
the the initial period when supposedly
the rental of the tank has had paid it
off
um thank you for your question the
complaints I've heard about are people
have owned their tanks or they buy a
house with a tank
they've never signed a contract or an
agreement with the company when they
call they may get delivery they may have
deliveries for one one of my
constituents got deliveries for 10 years
and then he started being charged a
rental fee
I've heard complaints where they've
owned the tank they've never or they've
never paid a rental fee but if they go
without a fill up
um they'll pay like they'll waive a
rental fee if they haven't gotten a fill
up or an order so let me give you an
example let's say someone goes three
years without
um or I think there's one example where
somebody had a propane heater on a
swimming pool and after a few years they
decided not to heat their pool anymore
the heater had broken so they're not
ordering propane pain so the company
didn't is now charging them rent because
they're not ordering propane
representative munz has a question thank
you Mr chair I had I've had some
experience with propane dealers myself
um
uh I see that AmeriGas is mentioned
quite a bit in your in your your
testimony is that does that seem to be
the one vendor that's generating most of
the complaints
as I've said I I haven't done a
thorough objective survey of different
companies but that is one I've heard of
a lot I was actually surprised in the
response I got that there were other
companies mentioned too
so but I think AmeriGas is probably one
of the major ones mainly because there
representative Summers has a question
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question I'm one of those
propane customers as well
Ernie I know it's not listed at least I
don't think it's listened here but have
you had issues with folks when they try
to change from propane company to
another about the ownership of the tank
the buying and the selling of the tank
the transfer the tank from one company
to another
oh yeah I've heard a lot of complaints
from constituents where their tank may
have been owned by one company they go
to switch and the company
um like charges them an exorbitant fee
to take out that tank to have the new
company or they won't transfer ownership
of the tank it really there's a lot of
representative munz has one more
question sorry just thought of something
um is is there any legislation on the
books currently that governs propane
sales
um I I did some research no not really
not at the customer level there is some
legislation regarding industrial propane
distribution and
um taxes and fees or conditions for like
industrial storage or propane but I
didn't see anything that is at the
did you also consult with the Attorney
General's office their consumer products
uh division to see if there was any
books any laws on the books about
propane there no not at the no no I
haven't okay sure great thanks
all right so you know further questions
we appreciate you being here and
testifying and introducing uh this Bill
thank you thank you very much and now
we'll get to to query the
representative or the gentleman
representing the propane gas Association
thank you Bob we appreciate it seen you
around the halls a lot I don't know if
you've testified before the committee or
recently
yeah
okay
well the floor is yours
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee for the record my name is Bob
Scully I'm the government Affairs
lobbyist for Propane Gas Association of
New England uh the letter that I
distributed to you comes from Leslie
Anderson she had a conflict she could
not be here today she's actually in a
propane meeting
um
down in New Orleans so um I am not going
to read this to you I'll try to recap it
as best I can
um if you take a look at this we are in
opposition to the study don't usually
say that but we think what our industry
can do out there there's about 30
different propane dealers in the state
of New Hampshire she has listed in other
paragraph some of the uh charges that
you might see or different charges that
you might see for deliveries and storage
and um
types of deliveries you get on volume so
the prices will vary and then more
importantly to the the issue that
representative rung raised and in full
disclosure I'm also from the town of
Merrimack and a constituent a
representative wrong I've known her for
quite a while so we take this serious
um
so the last paragraph in here you'll see
that um Leslie Anderson who is the
president of P gain has offered to
directly get involved
with complaints for the consumers to get
involved with the owners of these
companies to help find a resolution
um
to the question that representative munz
asked earlier
um every once in a while you have
someone in the industry that causes
problems for everybody
so the answer to your question was yes
from my perspective okay so we can help
the previous president of uh P gain was
Joe Rose and this is how he helped
facilitate some of these problems the
difference between propane and oil
anybody can put oil in your tank
um
but there is laws about propane and only
the owner of that tank can move it and
that's where some of these complications
come from so I would offer to this
committee that if you have constituents
that are having or yourselves that are
having propane problems um if you give
Miss Anderson a call she will take care
of that she's done it in the past
um and and if this committee sees fit to
move forward with the study committee
which we don't see a need for that um
then I will make some of our members
available to you
okay I think we're going to have a few
questions for you and we'll start with
representative Doug Thomas
thank you Mr chair uh thank you for
taking my question
um I'm a bit I guess it might be just
the wording or the tone of the wording
I'm I'm a bit taken back by in your
Latin in the last paragraph here where
it says that if if consumers do not like
the charges on their build they can
change companies uh that that's a little
bit not very helpful I'm just kind of
why do you think that
there is not a need for a study
committee on this when we we see some
some information like this uh it appears
not to be very helpful to the consumer
so why don't we need a study committee
to see what's really going on here
I think the members the 30 companies
that sell propane in the State field of
consumers can choose who they want to
and if they're not happy with one you
buy a car at a car dealership and if
you're not happy with that car you can
go elsewhere I think it's kind of it's
follow up um I don't think Leslie
Anderson who drafted this was trying to
be flippant with it I think she was
trying to say the consumer ultimately
can decide who they buy fuel for I think
I have one follow-up
follow-up so my follow-up question would
be
people are reticent to change when they
don't really want to is there are there
penalties for changing companies just
because they don't like one uh what what
are the ramifications if someone wants
to change a propane company because they
just don't happen to like one is your
cost involved for them right there
should not be most companies work
together with each other when it goes
from one provider to the next
so if there is a problem here that like
representative wrong described if
there's our issue with the consumer
these folks here at P gain are offering
to help
I'm going to car call on representative
Bernardi in a in just a moment but first
I have to make a comment here
because as representative Doug Thomas
points out
the line that says if consumers do not
like the charges on their bill they can
change companies I happen to know that's
not true
my next door neighbor
was a company it was a
went with a company called AmeriGas and
they had a thousand gallon tank that
they put in their backyard the man who
um installed the tank was the Builder
and he owned the house lived in it with
his family
and after 10 or 12 years they decided
they wanted to change companies
because they found a supplier who would
sell them propane for less money and our
AmeriGas refused
to
transfer ownership of the tank to
another company
and they had to go round and round and
round with AmeriGas and finally reached
a resolution where they dug up the tank
a thousand gallon tank it's a huge tank
they dug it up in their backyard and
AmeriGas came and got it and then they
replaced the tank and changed companies
that
that doesn't mean it that they can just
change companies without a huge hassle
and so understood uh I realize that's
not a question and I apologize but I
just had to get that off my chest
because my next door neighbor was was
quite upset about it representative
thank you uh chairman Bose I I was going
on exactly the same issue and I'll I'll
relate my story I have a thousand gallon
tank in my backyard that I put there uh
22 years ago uh and uh in the in the
plan it basically said you buy gas for
us for 10 years you own the tank yet I
kept getting fees up until two years ago
and finally I just
exploded with the company and said why
am I paying Annual fees for a tank that
nominally I oh paid for 10 years ago
because I used gas from that tank and I
had those
nominal fill levels all all along so
there appears to be an issue here that's
beyond how it's being described and can
be addressed and I I would what I would
ask is why is it not appropriate then
for you folks to hear these issues
because I think the companies are going
to have to come up with a change in the
way they do business here or we change
the law about how you can fill a tank
and make it just like a an oil company
can fill any tank you know if they have
appropriate safety training you know I
don't know what the issue is that
requires the resolution but it's clearly
not addressed here right representative
for my edification what company was
yours
uh Northeast Utilities okay
representative berezny has a question
thank you chairman and thank you for
taking my question
um I understand you're coming out
against this bill but if this bill were
to pass are there any things you would
like changed or any suggestions as far
as the membership makeup or what the
outcome of the of the bill or the report
uh if the bill wasn't helpful with your
with the committee's permission if the
bill were to pass I would just I would
make available to the committee for the
study a couple of members from the
propane industry to come and sit down
while you folks have a work session
okay thank you representative Wendy
Thomas has a question
thank you chair
um
to
I don't have
probe trying to figure this one out so
if you like representative
representative Bernardi he he has a tank
and after 10 years he's supposed to own
it
going on he's still paying a fee is that
and if something happens to the tank
it's not him who who does the repair
correct it's the propane company
representative Thomas I don't know the
answer to that question because I don't
know the relationship so I don't want to
give you misinformation but I'd be happy
to find that out for you I'm just
wondering if this fee is considered
almost an insurance fee as opposed to a
rental fee I'm just I mean I I have two
propane tanks in my house in Merrimack
and if I have something go wrong they
come and fix it but that's me okay thank
you okay thank you representative
Summers has a question thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question mine granted I have issues with
tanks as well but my question is about
the volume of refill if I had an oil oil
heat at home if I wanted 50 gallons 500
gallons or a thousand gallons it'd be
totally up to how much I wanted to put
in but then propane it restricts you to
where you have to fill at least 50
percent of your tank nothing less and
even if you don't have 50 available
they're going to charge you fifty
percent even if they can't even fit it
in the tank why is this so and how is
this legal
uh representative thank you for the
question I um I I wish Miss Anderson was
here so she could answer that I don't
know what the relationship is and why
you can have
um different requirements and I'm happy
to find out and bring that to you but I
I don't want to misspeak and I have
haffner's natural gas okay
representative Kaplan has a question
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question uh you mentioned that
you've had uh similar situations in the
past with with companies that you've
characterized as Bad actors or you know
people who are not doing what they
should do and that you facilitated
agreements so I'm just curious do those
agreements include restitution for the
people involved for the clients
um I know in the past that P gain
um gentlemen it used to run his name was
Joe Rose and Leslie Anderson has
replaced him in the past when there were
issues like this
um they worked to rectify the problem to
the consumer's satisfaction I would hope
so
um I I don't know at what point you know
the you break off on a financial side
but if you can't move a thousand gallon
tank
um that obviously that's a really big
problem okay I recognize that and if
we're talking about
you know a hundred dollars and I don't
know where that goes in relationship to
what customers do for their consumers I
would hope they'd take care of their
Customer because if they don't then I
think they have the you know they should
have the ability I'll use that word to
use somebody else so um I know that's
not answering your question directly but
I do believe that there are issues got
rectified to their satisfaction in the
past that's why she's offering to help
with this now
representative Reynolds has a question
thank you Mr chairman is Amerigas which
I understand to be a a nationwide
company which may have be in the
practice of buying up smaller companies
in
in our region are they a member of
propane gas Association of New England
they are
thank you
representative munz has a question thank
you Mr chair and thank you for
acknowledging uh my uh my struggles uh
you're welcome thank you
um I I you know not not really a
question but I guess the only thing that
I would I would suggest is that um you
probably have you know a couple bad
apples and you know I think it's just
important to get in front of that and
try to address it as quickly as you can
with with those individual companies
happy to do our best representative
Corman has a question
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question so in in this letter
from Leslie Anderson uh it's it suggests
if a customer is having difficulty with
a particular company Etc reach out to
our association and our association
we'll do stuff
do customers know this do we expect
customers to know to do this is this
included in billing information sent to
customers no I don't think so and I'm I
mean so
yeah
when he gets to this level we're having
discussions here it's obvious a problem
out there so what we're offering or what
they're offering to this committee is to
assist in trying to make the problem go
away as best they can
um sounds like there are some greater
problems it also to me sounds like
um there is one deal that is more
problematic than others okay and maybe
if that one deal wasn't more problematic
I wouldn't be here today
maybe I would but um
I don't believe so representative
representative partial has a question
yes thank you chair both and thank you
for your testimony
um you've referred that there have been
problems in the past
um
I would love to know when I this may be
a hypothetical question I don't know
um
compared to our other
um energy suppliers that we've given
monopolies to such as the oil and the
natural gas uh any any energy supplier
do you think that the uh
number of incidences
in the past where we've had difficult
situations is greater within the propane
um probably not I mean uh
the one reason is more difficult in the
propane industry is because there is a
law that requires that company to come
get their tank and remove it's there for
safety reasons oil doesn't have that
and one quick thought about
follow up
and uh do you believe that a study
committee could establish whether or not
these uh artist aberrations that can be
dealt with or whether or not it's
endemic of uh a situation that requires
further legislation
so I've been here for 34 years and after
listening to this committee and the
issues that are raised here I'm happy to
work with the study committee if that's
what you want to do
thank you there you go
representative closure did you have a
question
thank you chairman Boltz
um real quick I'm another one on this
committee was issue with a propane
dealer I don't need to go into it but
yes
it's easier just to pay to feed than the
okay that sounds ominous
representative brezhny has another
question thank you chairman and thank
you for taking my question
um in the testimony here it says for the
organization for your organization it
says we exist to serve the propane
industry by promoting safety education
and public awareness of the uses of
propane
um for promoting is so does this
organization not handle situations of
like policy between the you mentioned
um earlier that transferring tanks from
one cut from one provider to another
that each provider will will kind of
negotiate amongst themselves is that a
uniform process that an organization
like this provides or how do they how is
their consistency between
different organizations trans so how
it's supposed to work and how I do
believe it works in most cases if I was
to leave
company X to go to company y those two
companies would talk
one would purchase what's left in a tank
make restitution back to the to the
other dealer or the homeowner and that's
how this works it does work that way
most of the time it gets magnified when
we have issues now where we're dealing
with it with the dealer okay
um and uh that is
that creates problems see once again oil
is different oil anybody can put the oil
in your tank okay they don't have that
problem there so propane gets and has
another step it was put there for safety
reasons
um
and unless that part changes
um you you can't go from Bob Scully
propane company to representative Oaks
propane company without
working it out amongst the companies so
when a company does not behave properly
and do what they're supposed to do then
we're here talking today but most of
follow up thank you uh just just to
clarify my question so what I'm what I'm
asking is does this organization provide
some
sort of framework for all of these
different companies or provide some
policy or guidance on how to do some of
those things where it's multiple
organizations that interact with each
other
so the company Pro P gain will assist
when there's problems like this I mean
they have to be careful when they work
together with you know with um when you
start getting together and talking about
money and stuff like that they have to
be very careful
um
when so they have a board of directors
that meets
um I would imagine they discuss many
things I think
if they if I was to have those 30
companies in a room here today or 30
plus I would probably guess that 95 or
99 of them would tell you that they do
the way I explained it
um
so P gain I do not believe goes out
there
and and promotes all this they do this
their companies do this and when their
companies stub their toe they're
offering to assist
I'm sorry if not answering your question
the way correctly but that's
what it is I think representative Doug
Thomas has another question uh thank you
Mr chair thank you for taking my
question just because you mentioned your
shall I say time and Service uh with the
association and everything
can you relate on what you've heard here
today
the issues that you're hearing can you
relate to to
pre-pandemic post-pandemic uh
pre-recession post recession have you
heard of these issues before in your in
your experience in your tenure here
or is this something that is
all of a sudden new and recent to you
that would perk our ears up that would
I do not believe the issue that we're
talking about today has anything to do
with the pandemic
so
um I've already testified on behalf of
the folks that I represent that they'd
prefer not to have the study because
they think they can resolve the problem
but I've heard multiple
personal stories here around the table
what's going on so I am happy to bring
if this is what the committee wants um
owners
not from AmeriGas to this table here
okay to talk about how and they can
answer some of these questions more
specifically I wish Miss Anderson was
here because she worked for Dead River
right at his job so she understands
these things better than I do
um
but that's how I would bring a couple of
members here a couple of owners that
understand how this works if you do this
I mean then I guess you can decide later
on if you want legislation or not I
think the industry prefers not to have
that
um but you know maybe it has to have the
representative Wendy Thomas thought of
another question
um thank you this is actually a question
for the committee we've been hearing a
lot of stories of displeasure with uh
propane is there anyone on the committee
that has propane that is pleased with
what they have
okay all right thank you I just wanted
to know I would say overall I'm pleased
with propane as my as my heating fuel
but I have had a few problems myself and
I've heard from constituents and
neighbors of problems so
um I'd be inclined to think that some
action is necessary
representative Reynolds actually had a
question first
yes thank you Mr chairman and I'm trying
to be helpful here did you mean to say
that perhaps
the reason that the members of uh P gain
do not have
that that harmonization of of consumer
practices
is not one of the functions of P gain
and that that the reason that's not is
because you might be accused of
collusion if you if you got together and
talked about harmonizing the practices
well not to practice as if it gets down
to money it could be but I I don't want
to say that they don't talk I mean I
think the question was do they
is this something that they go down and
talk about to try to set up together and
how they work together I believe that's
just what they do already they should be
doing this
so if I had someone from White Mountain
Oil here or Palmer Gas and Oil here or
die for shard or City Fuel
or McLaughlin or any of these people
that offer both products I believe they
would all tell you
that this is what they this is what they
do this is their business practice
could I follow up question yes follow-up
I mean might it might it be that a study
commission which is all this legislation
is doing might it be that a study
commission could provide a helpful venue
a helpful forum for the the good actor
companies to share and come up with you
know good a set of good consumer
practices that the industry would abide
by it might
thank you
so representative Nancy Murphy would
also like to testify so
um let's give her that opportunity and I
thank you Mr sculling for being here
today
representative welcome to sdne oh
thank you chairman Vose and I will be
very brief because most of my points
have been raised I just wanted to
address both the change provider
response and the offer of the propane
providers to be available to address the
concerns
I think it's clear based on some
people's experiences here as well as the
testimony that was submitted that these
concerns have been brought to these
propane companies in the past and remain
unaddressed
um it's disappointing to me that the
propane companies recognizing that would
not support a a commission or committee
to take a look and see how they can come
together and offer
um services to New Hampshire citizens
that are not as conflicted and
um uh challenging as as they are right
now
um you know we see that you know
challenges of making that change happen
I my mother was 95 I know when she went
through this and it was not with
AmeriGas
um and uh just trying to get a propane
tank switched trying to get reimbursed
for what was in the tank when you're 95
almost 60 96 years old it's really hard
to make those multiple phone calls and
so I just think of our senior citizens
that are living in homes and one more
aggravation anyway I it makes sense to
me that the propane companies would
rather not have the involvement of a
study committee on one sense but I think
the testimony uh provided and the
committee's own remarks seems to
indicate how necessary it really is
um I think we need to be able to assess
both the types of concerns that citizens
have across the board as well as whether
there are just specifics to to certain
companies and uh on that I just ask that
you vote OTP on hb81 thank you
thank you appreciate you coming and
talking to us thanks so much anybody
have any questions for the
representative
seeing none thank you thank you uh we
have no more pink cards so there will be
no more testimony offered on this uh
proposed legislation
we spoke earlier today or maybe it was
yesterday I can't remember about
subcommittees
this bill appears to me to be an ideal
is there anybody in attendance by show
of hands who would be willing to serve
on a subcommittee to do more study on
this bill
I see one two
three
four
five so I think we have plenty of people
here who are interested in
studying this bill further so this is
not an early Bill we don't have to
exec it until probably the middle of
March so that gives us
pretty much a a month to five weeks to
look into this and I'm going to urge the
study committee
to not only examine the question of
whether a study commission or a study
committee is appropriate
but
whether or not it might be appropriate
to propose some other legislation
to deal with this issue now if the
subcommittee does propose additional
legislation we would have to have
another public hearing to discuss that
legislation
nevertheless
I would encourage the subcommittee to at
least consider whether other legislation
might be appropriate but beyond a study
committee or in addition to a study
committee or in place of a study
committee
uh representative partial
yes thank you chair Volks a questionable
procedure on that
um could we solicit a friendly Amendment
to the existing Bill if we wanted to
make some changes
certainly
and the study committee could feel free
to request the attendance of of other
persons to
provide additional testimony and
information on the question so for
example if Leslie Anderson might be
available
um subsequent to today maybe she could
come in and talk to the committee maybe
you could invite members of
the the other members of the industry to
come in
um CEOs or operations managers of
propane companies
whatever the subcommittee decides it
needs to do to gather appropriate
information would be
worthwhile and and the way to go so
representative Summers representative
partial representative Doug Thomas
representative Bernardi and
representative closure expressed
expressed interest in being on this
subcommittee
so
um I will ask representative Doug Thomas
to be the chair of the subcommittee and
he will call the first meeting and
notify the other members of the
and the clerk will record all this
information so that we won't forget it
later
representative naughter
thank you Mr chairman I just wanted to
say that I was writing things down and I
wrote down and what's exactly what you
said that my notes are a little
different I said the purpose of a study
is to recommend legislation farther down
the road and it sounds like the problem
is already known I wrote down the
problem is customer service so that
would be the focus of the subcommittee
is what they can do to
make these companies improve their
okay representative closure you had a
comment
thank you chairman both I'm sorry just
got back but I picked up on the end of
it because I had made a note that I did
not
and I am not looking for more
regulations
okay that's fine
um representative Thomas Doug Thomas
well uh thank you Mr chair that's
exactly my point to uh preeminate uh
representative Winnie's Thomas potential
question for the record it's
representative Doug Thomas that would be
the chair of the subcommittee
did I not specify that I apologize uh I
wrote Doug Thomas okay good
yes we're going to be doing this dance
s thank you chair
um
I could conceivably believe that the
scope of this subcommittee
would go beyond consumer
um
service
and there are other questions that I
would have asked today that I
I think I can find out on my own but I
think that they made their examination
the um
uh depreciation on these gas tanks is
something that concerns me
uh
and I would also add that I think that
while I don't like more regulation
myself I think having appropriate
regulation and safeguards protect the
consumers and our uh
our economy
if it's relevant we need to go ahead and
do that I don't think this is time to
have a full discussion of it by the way
should I do and I apologize for opening
the door on that
yes thank you let's wait until the
subcommittee meets to start those
conversations I think we've done Justice
to this bill here this afternoon with
this public hearing so I'm going to
close this public hearing and ask
representative closure to give us an
indication of what the blue sheet says
about it
House Bill 81 and the blue sheet it was
five in favor is none against
online it was two in favor one against
okay appreciate it
well I want to thank all members of the
committee for two days of of hard work
we got a lot accomplished today and
yesterday appreciate you all being here
and being attentive and asking good
questions and helping us get our work
done
we're not done yet of course this week
uh Thursday will be in session in the
house and then Friday we're right back
here for another full day of committee
meetings including an executive session
on five bills four of which are early
bills and we must make a decision about
those bills this Friday
so we will see you all uh on Friday or
actually on Thursday at session and then
again on Friday if you know that you're
not going to be available on Friday
notify your caucus leader immediately so
that a replacement can be obtained for
you for executive session
and with that we'll close this hearing
for today have a safe ride home and